Here we go.
Four,
three,
two,
one.
Get the sound of this popping up too.
Lazy Gentleman.
He just popped open and makers to taught
me sober.
October.
Can we look it?
Let me hear that.
Oh,
that does sound lovely.
this one's for.
This one's for fat Bert and 11.
I have 20 days.
Twenty days of sobriety then.
Ain't shit already did 11.
But let me tell you something.
What I've learned from this is we were
talking about before the podcast
started.
Want to hear me?
I'm going to pour some coffee.
Like an alcoholic.
It's a fucking a meeting.
I need a cigar.
I'm Joe Garcia.
Don't,
don't have cigars there.
I do.
Right there in one of these things.
I'm.
One of the things that I realized is
that if you work out like I'm working
out like fucking three hours a day
because I'm literally trying to kill
Bert.
I want to try to keep up with me.
You want him to die though?
I'm trying to kill him.
Yeah.
I'm trying to give him a heart attack
because you know what bothers me.
What?
This is all weed and there's mushrooms
in here and there's no cigarettes,
cigars,
I'm all good.
Shit.
Maybe I might've taken them out of here.
Homo door.
We're going to get a huge humidor for
you are a human.
What I realized,
this is why I'm trying to kill bird.
Yeah.
He likes to pretend that he's in shape.
Effort.
Effort is spectacular.
You know,
likes to pretend that he can push
himself.
Then he's got this incredible will.
He's in last place,
of course by quite a bit.
It's really sad.
Yeah.
And you know,
he takes days off when everybody
doesn't.
He take it.
I took three days off when I went to
Vegas.
I'm still in the lead.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I've seen.
I've seen his cooking show.
I know how I eat.
I've seen his fucking.
It's the booze man boost to his body.
I mean he's,
I'd love Bert and this is one of the
reasons why I'm trying to kill him.
I fucking hate him.
Let's fight burt.
You son of a bitch.
Want them to realize like,
this is not.
You're 10 years younger than me and you
have to take high blood pressure
medication.
This is all not good.
Yeah.
No,
it's not.
You're doing something terrible to your
body by drinking every night.
You shouldn't do it.
What did you do?
A bottle a night.
You think he gets down,
dude?
Yeah.
Down drink.
He'll drink a whole box of wine when
those box wines.
He's a friend frenzy.
Franzia freak.
He's an animal man.
He'll drink a whole Tito's like a whole
jug and I've seen that.
I've seen that.
Go down.
It's going on here.
He's freaking out the shirt off.
It takes his shirt off.
No Shit.
Does God look at that?
Look at that fucking stomach.
Here's the thing,
Kenny see his deck.
Do you think he sees his deck?
We can search for it.
Find it.
It's a heightened.
Heightened.
Go off.
What's the deal?
This is.
This is a podcast.
I saw this norton and hips.
He.
What was he?
He was saying on this halt as a wife or
something and to ask about what about
sex and his kids.
His kids were in the car.
Yeah.
Wonderful.
Yeah,
any pan and he panics.
He hasn't done that before.
Shit hammered.
Um,
but uh,
Tom lost all the weight when they just
had that weight loss challenge two years
ago.
Not last year,
the year before,
but score looks good.
Segora never gained it back.
No.
Yeah,
he looks fucking fabulous.
Fantastic.
And he's in the hunt.
It's like already in him or just behind
me.
Ran Him are neck and neck or number two
and he's just behind art.
And then cigarettes.
I mean when burt is way behind it,
but already needs to lose no weight.
Zero.
Wait,
he's already,
he's already finished.
Fuck,
he's down to 180 pounds.
He said for the first time in decades.
What is e six,
three,
six,
four,
six.
That's got to be right for um,
but he looks great.
He's thin and healthy for a snarly
Jewish guy.
He looks good.
Spaces bad,
but his body looks good.
Little angry without the wheat that this
is helping him.
And this is one of the things I was
saying is that I'm working out,
like I'm literally working out two,
sometimes three hours a day.
You do to,
you split it up or you just don't want
to go high?
Go Ham.
Fuck,
I'll just go hard.
I'll just mix things up like I'll run
and then I'll come back from running and
I'll kick box.
Then I have to kickbox I'll get on the
elliptical machine or I'll lift weights
and after I lift weights and then I'll
get on the fucking echo bike.
You know the echo bike thing and then
I'll get on the versaclimber and then
I'll get on the rowing machine.
I just do rounds when I can't run
anymore.
Look at this fucking puddle.
I left behind.
This is a puddle on my elliptical
machine.
She's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
I mean it was crazy.
This was two hours on the elliptical
machine and this was.
I just wanted to see what's possible and
then how I felt the next day I felt
fine.
The thing is I work out a lot already
so,
but now my body's just adjusting to like
a ramped up schedule.
It doesn't work out at all.
He hasn't worked out in 10 plus years.
So for him this is like a whole new
thing,
but he still second place.
It's his mind or he's got a strong mind
and he's,
he's,
he's got a will.
So what does the instagram was just
gonna finish somewhere in the middle.
So my,
when he never know what you think will
come,
come up,
probably won't beat me.
No,
there shouldn't be much anger.
Shouldn't be something big.
Big on the line.
Yeah.
There's nothing online.
Belt should be something big to finalize
that belt.
Jamie,
some good artwork.
Which folks get at me on instagram.
So grandpa,
use the Hashtag.
Use like at Joe Rogan tagged me.
And if you win I'll give you 500 bucks.
Oh,
okay.
Look at that.
People are scrambling.
Depends,
writes up with the best design.
I'll give you 500 bucks if I don't
choose anybody.
Nobody gets shit.
We have an artist who's anybody.
You burn the money.
That's what Joe's going to do is going
to burn it quick.
Yeah.
We need a quick.
I have an artist is trying to work on it
too.
So there's a run,
there's like a,
there's a mad run here,
but um,
the um,
the,
what I was gonna say is all bullshit
aside and jokes and I do love.
I do love everybody else doing this,
but all jokes aside,
I have zero anxiety,
zero worry,
zero stress.
Like when you burn your body out like
that,
do two hours of working out a day.
Not yet.
I don't give a fuck about anything.
Like I'm in traffic.
People cut me off.
I'm like,
fuck,
fuck.
Go ahead.
Cut me off.
Dickhead.
Who Cares?
I'm not angry like it does nothing.
What is it?
Because your body will burn.
You think you're just so fucking
exhausted.
I think this is my feeling.
I feel a lot of those.
I have those feelings that you have,
whether it's anxiety or stress,
it's just extra energy that your body
has.
It's unnecessary.
It's unnecessary energy and it's just
like your body's looking for trouble
that isn't there looking for danger,
that isn't.
They're looking,
looking for something that's going to
like steal your food or fade your
village,
all that shit because who's going to
kill my family?
Well,
I think your body has to have a certain
way.
We're designed right for all the years
that we were running away from wild
animals and other tribes and all that
shit.
I think your,
your body and your brain have a certain
amount on reserve,
always looking for some sort of danger.
You're a see a deer in the wild that's
like,
oh yeah,
twitchy and yeah,
they sit here and around the mountain
lion outline is that a mountain is a
mountain lion in my neighborhood by the
way.
There is,
yeah.
The neighborhoods.
One of the neighbor spotted a mountain
lion.
You've got your fucking good luck.
Shooting them out in line with.
Would be fun though.
Huh?
You'd have to.
The odds of you shooting them out.
Yeah.
What is that?
That walks by.
That lady.
Is that a cat?
That's a fucking.
No,
that's not a cat.
It was a mountain lion because of how
it's tail popped up and it looks like a
lion,
but it's just way too casual walking by
her.
She doesn't give a fuck.
She doesn't know what it is.
It definitely looks like cat.
She thought it was a dog.
Huh?
It kind of looks like a dog.
It's this way to calm the way it walks.
Buyer.
That's not a wild cat.
I think that's a dog man,
but it doesn't look like a dog.
Maybe a mountain lion made its debut.
Nobody knows what the fuck it is.
Fine or not.
In wildlife experts are looking at that
video and they'll see like,
I'm not a wildlife expert,
but I've seen a lot of wildlife.
The tail does not look right at the
tail.
Looks like a cat does it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does see it again,
that tail definitely say cat doesn't
look that good dog tail.
It looks like a balancing tail.
Like if you look at what's wrong.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It kind of does look like a fucking cat
yet.
Let me say it again.
That's a fucking dog though.
It could be a dollar.
People trim their dog hair and they'd
make a way.
Man.
It's like the tail.
It's holding its tail in the air.
See what I'm saying?
Yeah,
it is.
We check the tracks and they were
definitely dog tracks,
so it's a dog to dog.
It's my dad.
I told myself I wasn't going to say the
f word anymore than I did.
It snuck out talking about a dog and
makes its way out.
I think this closet,
this dog identifies as a cat.
It did.
I heard the dog as a person.
Now that it doesn't.
It wants to be called cal Calvin.
That's his name.
Yeah.
The dog says,
I'm Calvin.
Well,
you have to respect its feelings.
It has every right to be whatever it
wants to be,
man.
You just assume that animals.
I fucked up.
I assumed it's identity.
It's identity.
Yeah.
That's fucked up.
That's a big mistake on my part.
We've got a lot of fucking nerve Joe
Rogan to have a lot of nerve that's
fucking deeply embarrassed by myself.
You need to go to a support group for
people who think that dogs are dogs,
not even a cat.
Maybe it's just a century and being
maybe identifies as like a sentient
being.
It's just a being.
It's an orb of energy on a dog.
Not a cat,
just a thing that exists.
Yeah,
and maybe we don't have the right to
define it.
I got right.
You call something a cat by whose
judgment?
By humans judged and that's a feminine
word and you assigned to us.
Yeah.
You see a cat the way you said it sounds
feminine,
but what about cool cat?
Like if you're a cool black guy,
he's like,
yeah,
he's a cool black.
People have their rules don't apply.
They don't use that anymore.
Do they?
Hardly anybody uses?
No.
No one's saying jive Turkey anymore
either.
Turkey was fun.
I bet though,
for a while.
Who Do you think was the last guy to say
jive Turkey in all earnestness?
I think I saw like a shitty movie in the
nineties were somewhat like a black
comic use jive Turkey.
Oh,
nick cannon.
I saw thing and nick cannon lookup jive
Turkey.
Oh,
dead serious.
He's a jive Turkey.
Yeah.
Oh,
but he was probably being silly.
You can't as a comedian in the loosest
sense of the word.
He does.
Comedy doesn't eat.
Sure.
He had a standup comedy special.
Yeah.
Look at Jamie.
Yeah,
Jamie smirking,
it was called his standup comedy special
was called a stand up.
Don't shoot that.
I'm dead serious.
She's called stand up.
Don't shoot any war or any war.
Uh,
um,
you know he wears like a,
a space suit.
Yeah.
What is it called?
Cat outfit.
He wears like a fucking.
What is it called when the Indian
Muslim.
Headwear?
Yeah.
Doesn't he know?
No job.
Job Job?
Yeah.
He wears a job.
Yes he does.
That's a fucking knit pant.
No,
not,
but the cannon.
He job.
He wears the Shit fucking Howard stern
was giving him shit about it forever
because he cute because he was wearing
it.
Watch out a little bit.
You'll put a little camera.
Sold you bro.
He wears a turban.
Alright,
wait a minute.
What the fuck?
Nick Cannon explains his reason for
wearing a turban.
Get to police on Ellen.
I just don't have any breath in my body.
What's this?
What is this explanation?
I don't remember what he said.
I don't know.
Some fucking bullshit.
A second.
You know me?
I'm a conspiracy theorist.
I think the government did that.
They set her up.
What is that about Mariah not.
I was simple a minute.
Hold on a second.
Ellen.
Fifty eight.
Then asked nick about Mariah's New
Year's Eve.
Televise performance was marred
by technical difficulties and he said,
you know me,
I'm a conspiracy theorist.
I think the government did that.
I think they set her up.
It was a distraction.
Oh,
his joking.
No,
no,
no.
See he said he was a comic.
That was hilarious.
That was so good.
Funny.
Why does he say I like his white spawns
jacket that's.
I've never seen a white one like that.
It's like an old school motorcycle
jacket,
but it's white guys can't wear white
jackets.
That's why now they can't.
Sure they can.
You can't wear a white leather jacket.
I can with hoop earrings.
Okay.
Yeah.
Go Latina hoop earrings.
I want to see you wear those.
If I had hair,
I wear braids.
That should be the bet.
Jackets.
Hoop earrings.
White guys.
They don't seem to get called out for
corn rows.
It's really a white girls can't wear
cornrows.
Yeah,
but white guy.
I do see white guys with cornrows.
I don't ever see white guys are this
nick cannon weight gain.
What would the fuck is wrong with
people?
Let the guy gained a little weight.
You fucking idiots.
Worry about yourself.
But reasoning for the turban,
I can't.
That picture that I posted on my
instagram about the British,
Iraqi gender queer,
whatever the fuck is,
look at this.
Quantum physics really helped me
understand my queer identity.
Um,
British Iraqi gay nonbinary and identify
as Muslim.
That is real.
By the way,
this is a video if you go to,
um,
who's instagram?
Oh,
James Woods posted it on his twitter
page.
If you go to James Woods twitter page
and he says that's all egg,
right?
That's what he said.
It's funny.
Yeah.
Or that's Sasha.
Sasha.
Baron Cohen.
Yeah.
If you go to his twitter page and you
find it from yesterday,
that's where I saw it.
And there's an actual video that goes
along with it.
Now,
here's what's interesting.
When you listen to this person,
I don't want to know,
is this something.
It seems a very intelligent,
like very intelligent person.
Sure.
But yeah,
he posts a lot.
All James Woods does all day is just
drink coffee and talk shit about
liberals.
Keep going down.
Yeah,
just keep going.
It was got some cavenaugh mixed in and
he's got some fake news mixed in.
It's in there.
I like beer and tea.
You like beer?
Just two days ago.
Now I keep going.
It might be in there.
Maybe deleted within a response to
someone.
No,
no,
no.
I don't think so.
Admired is Bam.
Okay.
Go live,
go large.
Go large on this.
Go logical line and bring it to the
beginning because this is quite
political.
Hold on to the beginning.
Here we go.
My name is cody or Glam room and I see
that you might categorize as
intersectional.
I'm British or rocky,
gay,
non binary and also identify as Muslim
and the glittery quantum physics has
makeup I've ever seen like any human
entity,
quantum physics has helped them
understand this queer identity.
Okay,
now listen,
she just fucking space cadet.
The pictures are insane.
The listen
glorious sect of physics that looks at
the Subatomic particles that govern our
world,
so inside the neutrons,
electrons and the protons and looking at
Decaux leptons those hakes,
whereas classical newtonian physics is
obsessed with the universal formula that
governor reality.
It's so fixed on resolute answers.
Quantum physics reveals that there is no
fixed reality and it's full of beautiful
contradictions.
Okay,
so here's my point.
You can keep going on and watch this,
but this is a very intelligent person.
So why am I so dismissive?
Why?
Why can't this person where like if a
woman was beautiful and she wore like a
dark red lipstick,
but she was talking brilliant science,
I wouldn't have an issue with it.
So why do I have an issue with this Glam
roof fella?
Character,
Glam row,
a fellow Glam roadshow.
Why do I have an issue with the bright
blue,
glittery lips?
The Literal Rainbow colored eye shadow
with glitter,
the false
[inaudible] nine.
Is that what the.
Is this the Kashi?
Sixty nine.
And I think the.
Here's my thing with this whole thing,
I don't give a fuck what you want to be.
Who you identify with.
I'm for real cool with all that shit.
I think this is like peacocking and it's
at is fine.
Is formed.
This is calling for attention.
So the reason that we all are like,
oh,
and when they get mad,
like what are you looking at?
You know what someone's like,
what are you looking at?
You like,
you,
you fucking did this show for me to see
otherwise you'd stay in private and have
your own life,
but you want me to react.
But why do I like some of it?
Like if there's a seven year old black
dude and he's got like a red velvet suit
on.
Well he looks cool as shit,
right?
With like a slick Dora and he's walking
down the street with a fucking snake
heads.
Silver Cane.
Hey Joe Rogan.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean I look at that guy or girl,
look at this cool motherfucker,
but he's peacocking as well.
Yeah.
But it's a different this.
But this is attention grabbing because
they want you to see,
okay,
these people are the people who do,
who want to be larger than life.
That do things like this to express who
they really are,
that they want to have a discussion
whether or not they want to have true
discourse.
They want you to go,
what is this?
What are you,
what they want that.
Then they also want to like quote
unquote inform you or argue with you
about who they are and what you said.
Identity.
Yeah,
but why?
That's my whole thing.
Why can't you just be.
Be The thing you want.
You don't need to have so many fucking
with that nine labels from rocky,
gay,
British,
Muslim.
It's like,
dude,
what you just your Glam Room agree with
you.
Yeah.
Be Glamorous,
but I also myself,
I'm questioning my own judgemental
nature.
You saying why don't prejudge because I
care because it's outside of the realm
of normalcy.
It would've.
This is the,
this is.
These are pretty fucking normal foods
from,
from jen,
from normal standards of what's kind of
the same thing you've seen for the past.
So we fit into the culture where we
don't stand out.
So we're not asking for additional
attention.
I don't.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
This is,
this is a call to attention to call to
discussion and again,
I don't give a fuck.
I don't have anything against this
fucking person.
I don't know him.
I don't give a shit about them.
I just know that this is clearly for you
to go.
What the fuck?
That's why they.
That's why that is.
What if I was dressed exactly like this,
but a thick rope chain with a star on it
that had all diamonds.
You want me to say something about it?
That's why you wore that,
right?
You'd want me to go.
Why the fuck?
Why are you wearing that shit?
Why the fuck are you wearing that?
And in fact it would be insane if I sat
here the whole fucking interview and
didn't end.
Wasn't like it didn't go.
What the fuck is that star?
Like the size of like a Mercedes emblem
diamond and you'd be the asshole if you
go,
Whoa,
whoa.
Oh,
what does this do I have to fucking do
you have to know my identity with my
part of my culture,
man.
Okay,
well explain it because I don't get it
because it's not.
What I'm fucking used to or okay,
how about a white guy who dresses like
that,
but he talks like he's not a white guy.
Right,
right,
right.
Like the whole,
well we'll do it.
This guy.
Here's that.
He's a great troll.
He's actually so good at it.
Do you think he really got pistol
whipped in Brooklyn and robbed,
or do you think?
No,
to him.
So I think that was all a big fucking
media push,
but I think he's a genius for doing it
because it got him way more attention.
I think rob,
but I think this kid is,
is actually very smart.
What do you say,
Jamie?
You got to stuff back.
It took his chain and shit and they gave
you that.
Real thieves don't give shit back.
You get the chance.
Go back sometimes.
What do you know about black culture?
Jamie's all pretend that was in the
motherfucking streets.
Listen guys,
sometimes the chains come back.
Jamie's got it.
I'm not saying how they get them back
for them back.
I'm on black twitter.
You guys don't know Jamie's like my
black friend mark.
I went to the drake concert.
Relax,
I got this.
I bought the Carter Five Fella's.
Listen Up,
Jay Z and beyonce will no longer speak
to Kanye and Kim Kardashian.
In fact,
according to the fucking fake news.
No,
it was just out yesterday.
Yes.
Yeah.
Disavowed Kanye west and Kim Kardashian
because of his position on trump.
Jamie's got to Google it,
but Jamie fastest one handed type in the
fucking business.
Look at that.
See it's over bitch.
Twenty two hours a guys motherfucker.
The Daily Mail sever ties.
It's in hot.
New Hip hop.com.
It's on an med.
What's nme and new media entertainment.
Sever ties.
Its over.
We severed ties,
motherfucker.
We're not talking to you anymore.
You don't come to our champagne parties
over bitch because people were waiting
for that album to watch the throne to.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
It's just an album yet.
Collab album.
Yeah.
Well Jay Z is probably like,
I can't do it.
This crazy motherfucker anymore.
You have it.
You know what?
This whole thing with Kanye and this
whole push about getting Kaepernick to
have lunch with trump.
Brilliant.
It's fucking pr.
I think he used the whole platform of
snl just to get trump to go.
I love Kanye.
He wants trump to be so in love with
Kanye,
wants trump to love him so much that
he's willing to actually take a meeting
with someone he's been publicly shitting
on for for a year now.
All trump has been doing a sand.
Kaepernick is a terrible representation
of this country,
a bad football player,
a bad person.
He had been dumping,
dumping them and and then Kanye is going
to sucker him in,
twist his mind into thinking he should
actually sit and have lunch with them.
I bet my life that'll happen.
That trump will go,
okay,
I'll take a meeting because I love Kanye
and it's just out of respect for Kanye.
So he'll get up.
He'll get him and fucking catherine.
Nick in the room.
I'm,
I swear to God.
Watch it happen.
I hope he does,
but here's the thing.
Donald trump is not a cop and he's not
shooting black people like the whole
thing is bizarre.
It makes no sense when
Kaepernick is on his knees during the
national anthem.
That's bizarre too,
because people were just there for a
game.
It's a game.
I completely understand that.
You're disgusted by police brutality.
I think virtually everyone is.
My take on it is it's first of all,
it's insanely difficult to be a police
officer.
You have a lot of people that are police
officers that have no business holding
that job.
They're under extreme pressure.
A lot of them have ptsd and a lot of
them,
they're bullies and they get into this
position because they want to be the guy
with the gun in charge.
Totally,
and then they have an opportunity to
pull that trigger and they do and they
face repercussions because someone was
filming it and I think that shit has
happened from the beginning of time.
Yeah,
of course.
And there's film.
There's a horrible film that we played
were.
There was a guy,
I posted it on my twitter.
It's fucking horrible of a guy shooting
a white guy who's crawling for his life
on the voice telling the guy to crawl
towards him.
Let me see your hands.
It's in Arizona and the guy's pants have
fallen down.
It keeps reaching back to grab his pants
and he goes,
he goes,
I will fucking shoot you if you grab
your pants and the guy is crawling and
his pants are falling down.
He tries to grab his pants and the guy
liked him up in the hallway of a hotel.
Yeah.
Fox just kills him,
fucked,
murdered him.
The guy was crying and begging for his
life and the cop was making crawl
towards him like,
why the fuck would you ever make someone
crawl towards you?
It's insane and he's giving them all
these confusing directions while he's in
full riot gear holding a gun.
Apparently the guy had a fake pistol,
like a water pistol or a water gun and
was holding it out the window and
someone saw it and they said there's a
guy with a gun.
So they came in,
they're ready to shoot somebody already
and then they see this guy,
but the guy was clearly not threat.
We'll see this in this guy had already
been in trouble for other police
brutality and then got kicked off the
force.
He got acquitted by the way,
with video,
got acquitted,
and then you've got acquitted of the
murder?
Yes,
acquitted.
He murdered this with the video with the
video,
got acquitted,
and then afterwards got kicked off the
force for something else.
He did.
So the guy was just an abusive guy and
he was just going off.
There's a lot of people like that.
Totally.
And there's also some that are racist
too.
It's not discounting racism.
There's some that are racist too,
but it's just a fucking insanely
difficult job.
But no one respects are very few people
respect and these people are in these
situations every day where their life is
in danger and their whole brain is
frazzled.
I'm friends with a lot of cops.
I know a lot of cops in my family.
I know a lot of cops from mma.
I know a lot.
I've known a lot of cops in my whole
life,
like my whole life growing up.
My,
my real dad was a cop.
I grew up like knowing cops when I was a
kid and then in an all through martial
arts,
new cops,
because cops are always taking martial
arts to learn how to defend themselves.
Right?
It's a fucking insane job,
man.
That's crazy.
It's fucked up and every day,
all day long,
you're dealing with people that are
committing crimes.
You're dealing with people that are
lying.
lying to you.
You pull people over there lying either
drunk or on drugs.
They've got a body in the trunk.
It's just lies.
Even a simple pullover is alive when it
faster.
We're going like,
no,
no.
Going over.
No.
I legitimately had a broken speedometer
once and a cop pulled me over and I go
to the skin.
It sounds so fucking stupid.
Must be nominated.
Doesn't work.
And he's like,
get that shit fixed.
I go,
yeah,
I should.
I should let me go.
You know why I'm white,
white dude,
white guy.
And it was only 18 at the time.
Black Dude.
He's like,
Bro.
And he's like,
get out of the car again.
It's,
you know,
it's not even something to joke about.
I'm sad that you just joked about it.
No,
but it is fucked up.
It's fucked up.
It is fucked up,
man.
But here's the thing,
right?
Football players like capita,
people like that,
they need because they want to.
They using their platform.
I mean,
I get that to.
You should use your fuck.
Everyone should use their platform.
Here's my thing though.
Has that helped in any way?
Well,
no.
See the problem is there's no.
There's no.
Okay.
The problem is if you said to
Kaepernick,
what's your end game to say,
stop all police violence is such a
vague,
broad thing.
Does it go?
Yeah,
just stop it.
It's like,
well that's not that.
This is to have a dialogue about.
It was what's important,
but the problem is they need to have.
We need.
There needs to be a bigger goal for why
people are kneeling because the
conversation has already been had.
It's not like we're kneeling so we can
talk about it,
what we're talking about it we need to.
There needs to be some kind of a,
an end game.
A goal,
a point of that,
it's not,
I'm not saying it's achievable,
it's not necessarily going to happen,
but you need,
you need something to to.
You
need something to get to because
otherwise this is just going to be this
weird turmoil between ultimately racist
people because truly the people that are
yelling about it that are angry.
I don't give a fuck the take a knee.
Are they still gonna play football.
Why do you care?
Yeah.
Like I like,
but ultimately people that are like,
you better stand up better stand up for
America.
Again,
the ideas that we're all on the same
team.
I know,
but there's no one to support the team,
but why?
Why Neil dirt.
But why?
Then like because just because people
were paying attention.
That's exactly right because the all the
eyeballs are on right?
But the idea about a nation about
everybody being on the team together.
So we're supposed to support these
ideals that this song is about.
I pledge of allegiance to the flag.
All this jazz.
I mean that's what we're doing,
right?
I know,
but I find it so odd that the things
have anything to do with one another.
I sat it on stage one time that I was
like,
it's a game that has no bearing on the
future of the United States of America.
You don't do that for anything else,
right?
You don't just.
You don't have like a dinner party and
play monopoly and someone's like,
we should say the pledge of allegiance.
Swamping.
The UFC stopped.
That I really liked was saying they
wouldn't do the fucking national anthem
though.
What are we doing?
We're here for cage fights.
These are just two men competing in a
sport,
but it was a big thing with boxing and
it still is.
I think she's still do the national
anthem before big boxing matches and
it's bold.
It's miserable.
So you see people saying,
and it's when people do that thing with
their voice,
they tried to be.
They tried it,
they tried to make it
shaky thing.
Hey,
that's the funny thing at any sporting
event in the middle of that,
up that last stretch,
there's always like 50,000
people.
I think the crossover is so fucking
silly.
We don't need to be singing about
America at sporting events.
It doesn't have anything that doesn't
have any.
The Olympics Olympics definitely.
That's what it's fucking about.
Controversy or country.
But during all this shit about the
Olympics,
I know,
but I'm just saying I get that fucking
national anthems at the Olympics.
That's what it is.
But this is just the packers versus
fucking,
you know the buccaneers that this has
nothing to do with the bearing of
American future.
Will the soldiers fought for your right
to be able to put soldiers,
fought for your right to be able to do
fucking everything can do.
Do we have to say it before this
podcast?
Right?
Okay.
We should.
As a God damn flag behind me.
No God.
Damn American flare but secret not the
fans don't know that Joe hates the
American flag on my phone.
Bitch.
Goddamn American seed.
This motherfucker.
This is trolling.
He's trolling.
Joe Is actually Canadian.
Nobody knows that.
Shows a Canadian.
She backed down Bro.
Conspiracy Rogan theorists online like
is joe actually born in Canada doing
Canadian propaganda on the sneak tip for
years.
Toronto's a great city.
It's my favorite.
What I'm looking at you with that maker
and I'm kidding.
No,
I'm loving
every second of it.
I was like,
this is like an ad for against sober
October is my birthday on Tuesday.
I'm not not drinking for.
Get it man.
Why should you?
Yeah.
What,
what did you think you'd be?
Do you think you would do sober October
and like take a day off for your
birthday and then get back to sober and
then.
Oh,
a day at the end of the month.
Start a day early.
I guess I could do it,
but I don't.
I don't.
I just died on Jamie.
What do you think?
I can't do it.
You would do sober November.
What about silver?
February.
It's only 28 days.
That's what's fucked up.
November history month.
That is the shortest.
The shortest month I said you said they
gave him.
What if,
what if?
What if it was picked with the NAACP?
Picked it out.
It just white whitey white people.
Being like this,
the shortest day crack ass fucking white
crusty looking billowing stinkin mother
fuckers.
I wish there was a good slur for
breeders.
You know,
for straight people that like faggot.
Yes.
Something like a,
you know what I mean?
Wouldn't it be good for us?
It was a normal cigarette.
Use It on yourself.
Nor you fucking normal.
You fucking Goddamn.
Pretty easy to cast basic fucking
breeding ass going out.
Penis in Vagina.
Dixie.
Pussies like fucking antiquated.
Loser.
Fucking arcane monkeys.
Stupid ass sperm soak in this
motherfucker.
And inside a women you fucking loser.
What do you do?
People like yourself.
You fucking loser.
There should be a word.
Yeah,
I do think there wasn't an I put on my
instagram yesterday that uh,
you shouldn't say pregnant woman.
Oh,
you shouldn't assume that the gender of
someone who's pregnant.
It was supposed to say to someone that's
people will like,
that's a troll,
right?
That's the onion.
No,
no,
no.
We are in the fucking twilight zone
right now.
Here it is.
All genders can become pregnant because
people of all genders can have the
reproductive organs to do.
So.
What in the holy fuck it sentence
instead of saying pregnant women try
using the phrase pregnant people keep
going down because people of all genders
can fall pregnant.
You can fall pregnant.
Fuck falls prey.
I fell pregnant,
Joe.
I fallen pregnant because people of all
genders can fall pregnant.
Can you call in if you're a man?
Can you call in work and say,
Hey,
I'm not going to be in today because I
fell pregnant.
They do give a maternity leave for guys.
Yeah.
Oh good.
Identify as pregnant.
Um,
I'm,
I,
I've just fallen pregnant.
I need to not come into work.
Yeah.
What,
how,
how has that work?
See,
but this is what's this.
this is why this is a propaganda
bullshit lie of like getting us all on
the same page of,
of not all genders can,
can have reproductive or.
And that's not true.
The reproductive organs,
it's really simple.
You can't fabricate it is too
easy to survive.
So people are coming up with all sorts
of different kinds of conflicts that are
not real.
I guarantee you all those people that
are doing this,
they're not working out three hours a
day fucking else they did.
They wouldn't be paying any attention to
this shit.
It's like this is nonsense.
Instead of saying women are pregnant,
say instead of saying pregnant women,
try using the phrase pregnant people.
Oh well they corrected themselves.
The posts should say,
become pregnant instead of fall
pregnant.
Thank you.
Are followership pointed this out?
You put it,
you wrote that yourself.
The language you use affects the people
around you.
People of all genders can become
pregnant because people of all genders
can have the reproductive organs do so
when talking about pregnancy,
try to use the language that is
inclusive of people of all genders.
Well,
there's 78 different genders now.
Seventy nine Joe.
Don't be so fucking ignorant.
Dude.
I hate when I do that.
You know,
it's no ms dot gender.
This kind of bullshit is due to boredom.
This is complete boredom.
Well,
it's also weak pussies.
These people that are doing this,
I guarantee you if,
if this is where you're looking for
conflict,
yeah,
you're fucking whole life has fallen
apart.
You're a mess.
This idea that you're proposing that
people of all.
First of all,
it's insulting to women.
It should be deeply insulting.
People of all genders can be pregnant.
The fuck they can.
You know how God damned difficult it is
for a woman.
Your wife hasn't been pregnant yet,
but let me tell you something,
man.
I've seen a lot of women pregnant.
It's rough.
It's insanely hard.
Women get pregnant and it's hard for
them.
Yep.
That's what gets pregnant fucking
difficult.
Their whole body goes through these
crazy hormonal changes that gain a shit
ton of weight.
They get insecure,
they have crazy mood swings,
chemicals in the brain changes
postpartum depression where they get
suicidal.
It happens in a lot of women.
The idea that all genders,
all genders.
No,
no bullshit.
Bullshit lies.
Biology motherfucker.
Fuck only.
Fuck the only.
There's only one.
There's only one gender that can become
pregnant.
A woman.
Yes.
That's a woman and that's the end of the
discussion,
but there's not an argument.
There's this new way of talking about
things that's filled with nonsense and
they.
This is where the fascism lies.
They want you to adhere to their rules.
Yeah.
One hundred percent,
and if they don't try to enforce this
year,
they shame you.
Try to go after you fucking ask for what
they are saying is literally against
science.
It's not scientific.
It's not true.
Now,
if you want to tell me that some people
like to identify as a woman and you
should talk to them as a woman and give
them a woman's name.
Sure,
totally.
I don't care that you think.
No problem.
If you want to listen,
that's my whole thing.
If you say to me,
I'm not a man,
I'm a woman.
Now go good.
Good for you.
That's fine.
I'm fine.
I don't give a fuck what you.
That's fine,
but you can't stand there and tell me
that anybody than a woman can
get pregnant.
Have a child at this is now we're
talking about like fake semantics.
This is phone.
That's phony.
Shit,
you've made that up.
It's also idiots.
It's all these weak people,
these weak minded.
The way I described the lady who tried
to bring a fucking emotional support.
Squirrel on the airplane.
What airline was it by the spirit too.
Oh,
I was hoping for around here.
Kanye talks.
Prison reform with trump.
Had lunch.
Okay,
play this.
Play this,
and please let's hear some volume here
and make more money.
That's one thing.
I never stepped into a situation where I
didn't make people more money so we can
empower pharmaceuticals.
Nodding factory.
We can bring that.
Only Adidas on shore we could bring
Foxconn is set up a factory and I think
Minnesota.
Wisconsin.
Yeah,
I love Wisconsin dollars a year and one
of the things we got to set is for to
have the highest design.
The dope.
This car is the most amazing outer.
Don't say dope.
I don't say negative words and to
liquid,
we just say positive,
lovely,
divine universal stuff.
Getting stupid.
Jesus.
Listen,
you dumb mother fucker.
Ford makes dope cars.
Okay.
Is he ever see a goddamned Mustang?
Gt?
Three Rs.
That's a dope.
Jamie.
Post up a picture of a Mustang,
Shelby Mustang gt.
Three slash 50 are quickly,
quickly all the tastes of that.
My fucking brain.
Give me a photo.
The new.
Oh God.
That's America right there.
You're telling me that's not dope.
You son of a bitch.
Jesus there.
Top left.
Top one there.
Right there.
Hey,
come on son.
That's dope.
You know like I could drive that the
raptor f 1:50
rapid.
That thing is fun.
As far about drive the Ford Gt,
the one that John Scene has just sold
for one point $3,000,000.
Pull up John.
Seen as for GT.
You don't think that's dope?
Well,
I'm not talking to you anymore because
our fucking conversations over now with
the doors up like doors,
Jamie.
That's what I'm looking at.
Fucking go big o.
If that's not dope,
Kanye.
I don't know.
What's the hope?
What are you going to teach the people
at Ford had to design cars.
Shut the fuck up and make your shitty
slides.
Positive words vacuum your slides that
are too short or were these God damn
yeezys that Jamie bought for me and I
will never wear show Joe.
Joe's never seen that video with the
little.
The little pump right the fucking fuck.
Now show him the picture of it.
Didn't bring it up.
Show him the picture.
Jamie.
Should go where the big suit.
He saw the box.
It's like they're wearing refrigerated
box.
This guy.
Okay,
so I'm just saying this guy is trying to
tell us about via dopeys.
This is his music video.
That fucking car.
You don't think that's dope?
That might be the dopest car the world
has ever known.
Slick as fuck.
Black for gt with red stripes.
This might be the most beautiful car
I've ever.
It's okay.
Let me rephrase this most beautiful
modern car I've ever seen.
It's a sexy fucking guys who was atj and
j.
fucking thing,
man.
Look at that thing.
Good.
Jay Go,
golly.
What a beast of a fucking automobile.
Kanye.
That is fucking cold as ice.
I think it was just saying to make them
here.
Shut up Jamie.
Goddammit,
you shut the fuck up.
Stupid Kanye West.
Give them a spelling bee first.
Give them a spelling bee and then you
can say,
listen,
if you can get here without using the
red squiggly line underneath you on your
phone.
Have you the fact that Donald's nodding
at him,
I know he's sitting there going forward.
Should be doping probably sitting here
going,
fuck,
did I get to this position where I'm in
the Oval Office?
You know why?
Because he wanted to see Kim Kardashians
so mad.
He was like,
I'll let this motherfucker come back
face.
Look at Donald's face.
Yes.
Imagine these photographers of like,
man,
I've taken.
They've been in such important rooms and
they're like,
now I'm here.
But see the Kanye thing is like,
they just let them rant about shit and
no,
no one goes,
wait,
what?
Like no needs to take his meds.
He's not taking his meds.
He even said that he stopped taking
meds.
Right?
Jamie's not the whole thing.
It's like,
yeah,
take your meds,
Bro.
Beds made them gain a ton of weight and
he looked really fucking spaced out.
Did you ever see fat?
Kanye,
Kanye was pulpit here with Kanye with
the meds,
so what happened was after he gave his
support for Donald Trump,
he said,
I didn't vote,
but if I voted I would have voted on
trump.
Like Lugoff Biggie.
Got they.
They loaded him up with pills and when
they loaded him up with pills,
you vanished for awhile.
Canceled his tour.
He was like having a fucking serious
nervous breakdown and he got big fat.
That's usually.
That's when he.
That's when he was on the pills.
Oh yeah.
Mentally fucking stable.
No,
I'd rather be fairly stable.
This is what I think because of sober
October.
I think he just needs to work out.
She was just going to say I don't,
I don't.
I don't think.
I don't think it's a part of his
lifestyle.
I think his lifestyle so.
Well that's not true because one of my
friends was his trainer,
so he does work out.
You gotta train it for a walk.
She,
I feel like he doesn't.
Yeah,
he seems like God that just doesn't have
the.
He.
He had a trainer.
Yeah.
Trust me.
That's when he lost weight.
After all this bullshit is a long time
ago,
he had a trainer.
I want to say my friend was doing it
unless he looks really good.
Good,
great.
Six or seven years ago.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I don't want to disclose any trainer
client confidential shit,
but working out.
He was working out,
but the point is,
look,
the guy's fucking obviously a little
looney,
but that's also why he's so fucking
creative.
Fuck yeah.
I mean that's why his music so good.
I mean,
I.
I don't think you have to be completely
normal.
Look,
most of my best friends are out of their
fucking minds.
You're not fucking normal.
I'm not knowing I got real problems.
Yeah.
All right.
Well we all do.
Anybody that's good at something,
but I also have a lot of self
examination and that's what he's
lacking.
Self awareness.
I examined the things that I think and
say and how I interact with people and I
don't always get it right,
but when I see him doing that holding
court in front of the president of the
United States with a mag maggot hat on,
like in front of all these fucking
people,
taking pictures of him like this is
preposterous.
I don't use words like dope because I
try to use only positive,
like lovely.
Dope is positive.
It's dope.
Like you.
You sent me a text and I sent you texts.
Let's do 10:00
AM.
Dope,
dope,
dope.
Great.
Perfect.
Plus,
great lesson.
It's not negative.
Next time you texted me,
I'm going to go divine.
Yeah,
if I can.
When I saw your car,
I was like,
dude,
that's a dope car.
It's divine Joe.
Oh,
it's lovely.
It's lovely.
It's wonderful.
Wonderful.
Few Times in all honesty and I always
feel like,
well,
you sound like a bitch a little bit,
a little bit.
Hey,
how was your.
How was that thing you did yesterday?
It was wonderful.
Oh,
okay.
It was wonderful.
It just swallow Cox.
It's one of those words that you use
when you're hanging around with actors.
He was wonderful.
He was a wonderful,
wonderful performance.
Especially when you're talking about a
woman.
She was exquisite.
Wonderful.
Her performance was so wonderful.
You know the word that I hate.
Brilliant,
supportive woman.
I hate brilliant.
And the actor community people say
brilliant bothers me.
So when they go,
oh my God,
just brilliant.
You're like,
unless it's brilliant.
Yeah,
but the rarity of that word should.
It should be so it would be used so
less,
but you go see Roger Waters at the
Hollywood bowl and like,
fuck.
It was brilliant.
Big Difference.
That's of course,
that's an issue.
That is brilliant,
but that's.
That's decades of hard work and talent
and so many things coming together to
make.
I've watched him do the wall here,
what?
Three years ago at Staples Center and
and I was sober rish.
Let's just say that I was so British.
I was microdosing and it was sobering.
Yeah,
it was.
I wasn't like lit up,
but I was in a good space.
It was maybe one of the most incredible
visual things.
Visual concerts.
I've ever seen in my fucking life to
watch them.
You ever seen that?
They build the wall on stage as he's
performing and they tear it down in the
middle of it all.
Damn.
It was fucking.
It was visually one of the most stunning
concerts I've ever been a part of to
watch them make.
It's not just a band playing.
It was them making visual art while he
was telling this story through music and
I was like,
this is why I'll pay hundreds of dollars
to watch somebody.
Not,
not just to hear fucking Tom Petty Way.
Allow those tickets are the same amount
of money,
but you don't get the show like with
waters,
you get like this fucking visual
experience.
He's incredible man.
Yeah.
He's incredible.
Anti trump shit at his concerts to right
with pig heads
and she had a lot of government,
a lot of government shit.
Yeah.
He gets into a lot of that bullshit,
but I mean it's,
it's,
it's visually stunning as fees.
Nuts.
Yeah.
Because
he's.
So.
That's what I was saying.
He's so good.
He's beautifully insane.
Crazy.
Yes.
All these airplanes flying overhead and
then they float.
Yet they flowed big pigs over you that
drop propaganda notes and shit.
Dope as fuck.
Dope.
It's dope.
It's fucking incredible.
Yeah,
but I mean that's what I'm saying.
Visually.
It's fucking just unbelievably beautiful
man.
So is the Jamie,
you're.
You're a part of black.
Twitter is the black community
abandoning Kanye and there are only
white people accepting him now.
That's Jamie.
You're black.
If I see a lot of the all,
all white people.
Alright.
Excuse me.
Alright,
can you say all white?
I don't think Jamie's Jamie's part of
the black.
Oh wait,
let's define it right now.
What's out white?
What would you call all?
White.
All white would be.
I'm not all right yet.
They're not there yet.
All white is all the batter's box.
Yeah.
They're like on their way.
The next step.
What's all white?
What would you call out?
White.
Who like,
give me an example of a person who is
all white.
It was whiter.
Here's one.
I'm the fucking Dilbert guy.
Scott Adams.
She's all white.
Who's that?
Because he's not all right,
right.
He's a really brilliant guy,
but he's like Sorta,
oh the comic seniors,
like,
yeah,
seems like he had and I liked the guy a
lot,
but it seems like he had these ideas
about trump and now he's always just
trying to defend them with some sort of
circular logic and weird phrasing and
he's a super smart guy,
but he never said a single negative
thing about trump.
It's always,
well it was a brilliant negotiator and
what he's doing is so strategy and he's
very persuasive and I'm like,
yeah,
is he,
is that what's going on or is he just
like flying by the seat of his pants
because he's a fucking maniac.
And Are you just trying to sort of
justify all the other shit that you've
said about it?
And that's really good.
That's what they do because that's what
it seems like to me.
People don't like Scott Adams.
Yeah,
a lot.
I like it.
I just think he's a very nice guy.
He's all white,
all white.
He,
they dance on this line that's like,
listen,
not offensive over my house.
Now they just have dinner with him.
He's more youthful guy,
he's he.
He's more into those positions that he
wants to probably admit,
but from a surface level he's like,
no,
no.
Like what positions?
Doggystyle style.
Alt right.
None.
No mission.
What's an ot?
What,
how do you think all white people fuck
that?
Don't fuck.
They stand up in the shower.
They,
they,
they do this the whole time.
They fuck if you do that.
If you fuck with one hand up like
Hitler,
but that hand is touching the glass in
the shower.
Then it's all white.
Fucking.
This is all white fucking business.
I think there's a lot of all whites out
there.
Let's,
let's figure out who was all white
white.
Who's my best example of a white person
that I know.
That's okay.
Like one of them,
one of them hot.
It's always talking about
white people issues is Tomi Lahren alt.
Oh yeah,
she's old white.
Yeah.
All White.
Not all right.
But all white because you know what's so
clever about that fucking chick that
she.
She did an interview with that Trevor
Noah kid on,
um,
what the daily show.
And then afterwards they hung out and
the Paparazzi,
I picture them smiling and hugging and
all shit,
you know,
in the street says Hollywood is fake as
fuck.
Like she does this game,
but it's like she's not fucking racist.
She doesn't hate people of color.
She likes to be evocative,
provocative.
She likes to take a conservative
stances.
Well that's what they say about Ann
Coulter,
that if you'd talked to Ann Coulter,
she's actually a lovely person.
Will look at it like this.
There's a map.
You can bring it up.
Jamie.
Jamie,
bring it up.
There's a map of a PR.
I'm a categorical porn percentages in
the United States and the highest
percentage of white and black porn is in
the south.
Like the Bible belt of a bit about it.
You did.
But it had to stop doing it because it
was going to drop the n bomb a bunch of
times on a bit.
I can see how that didn't go over as
well though.
It worked.
It worked or it didn't.
Yeah.
Or either crushed or it was dangerous.
Or after the show joe had to sneak out
fast.
I know that there was,
there was,
it was like in the Bible belt,
there is a chunk of the highest amount
of black dudes fucking white,
like black on white porn is in the most
conservative parts of the country.
Well,
my,
my take on it was that it wasn't black
guys there.
We're watching this.
Of course I know it's fucking white
dudes that are,
that wish their rights.
Angry fucking,
but I don't want some big white.
You put it in her ass.
You put that big beautiful thin skin.
Veiny black penis in my wife.
That chocolate dark snake stick and my
wife.
That's all it is.
It's all this fuckin like racial
suppression.
That's those people that like that play
the game.
That's all white.
They're not.
They're not all the way,
but they're.
There you go.
Most searched for terms the United
States Lesbian,
Texas is all lesbian,
California,
lesbian.
That's hilarious.
Stepsister.
On a second stop.
Look at this scan back in again so I
could see the actual title of this.
The most searched for terms in the
United States.
This is according to pornhub.
I'm get Montana and Colorado.
Is that what is the up up on top is at
Michigan.
What are those dates?
I don't know that.
Okay.
Stepsister is Minnesota,
right?
That's.
That's Minnesota.
What is the other two?
That it goes north and South Dakota was
lesbian and stepping on Wyoming.
No,
no,
that one's Wyoming guys.
That's Wyoming and Montana.
Wyoming is the square and that's the
only one that's pr.
There's two states that are perfectly
square.
How they pull that off color.
Colorado's perfectly square and so is
Wyoming.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
New Mexico almost had it.
That's crazy.
Like how jealous muscle.
Massachusetts Bay with goofy ass shit.
You fuck them.
Fuck everybody.
Fuck on that road.
I live in Florida is built like a Dick
and they got to look at Colorado.
Colorado is like a perfect square.
Florida's the dingleberry of the United
States.
Texas.
Just chaos.
Texas is just.
We are.
Whatever the fuck we are.
We're a boot wear.
Whatever the fuck.
So Louisiana is.
Okay.
So.
So I'll like.
One state is black.
He states that Ebony,
what does it?
Louisiana,
Louisiana.
Black Alaska stepmom.
George's black.
White isn't the map that I was thinking
of though.
There is another one where it was like
that.
It said black on white point.
How recent is this?
Don't go.
Don't go away.
Go back.
Go googling for yourself,
motherfucker.
Stop.
Look at MILF.
Where's MILF?
One state like Rhode Island.
Oh,
it is Rhode Island.
Scroll back there.
Keep it right there.
Don't move.
Oh,
that is Rhode Island.
Look at MILF.
Stepsister is Maine.
Maine.
Got that step sister.
Shit.
Wait a minute.
New Hampshire's cartoon.
Not The fuck.
What the fuck?
Three cartoon states for four.
Well,
that's Arkansas and Tennessee are
cartoon to.
Those are the two states.
They're 10.
It's like one state,
but this also gives me a little bit of
hope because Joe,
you've.
You've come from Massachusetts was still
lesbian and now you're still lesbian in
Chicago.
We were always lesbian.
I'm still,
I feel really good about my consistency
of my pornography state category.
How many are searching for lesbians more
than anything?
And look at Alaska step.
Mom was babysitting me.
Wilma.
Why the age?
Literally.
How about Ebony?
So only one state,
all three states.
Now one,
two,
three.
I like that term to ebony had been ebony
want to say black?
That's funny.
People type in black and they type in
evidence the only type in black and one
state because they don't know what
equity means down.
Okay,
Joe,
this is proving what we're saying is
well proven.
We're saying,
you know,
who's searching for ebony in Georgia and
in.
What is that?
And stop moving this.
Go Zoom in.
Zoom in.
This is a fundamental difference.
So Ebony down there in Georgia and in
um,
uh,
what is that Mr Shippee,
right?
Yeah.
The reason that those are ebony and
Louisiana's black is because ebony is
searched by black people,
black and searched by white people.
That's for sure.
One hundred percent.
Now you're right.
That's categorically ebony is a black
person typing black is a bunch of white
dudes being like Gimme a black porn,
right?
Chocolate,
big old chocolate.
Other Ebony up uptop.
Jamie,
what is the other ebony on the right
side?
What state is that?
Delaware.
I forgot.
Delaware is a state.
That's one of the mistakes you like.
That's a state.
How do we make,
how do we still.
They can't just get absorbed by another
state.
What is surrounding Delaware?
What's next to Delaware?
Maryland.
That's right.
Yeah.
Fucking forget about Maryland's all
about the lesbians,
so wait a minute.
They're ebony haunt.
That's so strange.
To go back to the scroll,
go back to the side so that it was
before was we read it all myself is only
one state.
That's weird.
That is Rhode Island,
right?
Yeah.
That little tiny ass bitch ass bitch ass
state.
How many Rhode Islands are in Texas?
Look at that.
There's
dudes who own a Rhode Island in Texas.
They own multiple.
One hundred percent.
Do you know there's like 8,000
ranches or something like that in Texas?
8,000.
Yeah.
Thousands of ranches.
That's fucking branches.
May there might be more,
because I was watching this on
television show and I think it was an
older television show number of ranches
in Texas.
Two hundred 48,000
ranchers.
Ranch is 248,000
farms and ranches covering 132.
One hundred $30.
Million acres.
Two hundred and 48,000
farms and rent.
Look at the Tivoli.
The commodities is all cows,
baby.
How do you define the difference between
farm and ranch?
That's actually extremely interesting.
I've always thought that it'd be the
same thing,
isn't.
No rancher isn't a ranch or farm.
I guess I'll go back up again.
Please stop scrolling.
Two hundred 48,000
farms and ranches covering a hundred and
30 point 2 million acres.
Next is the biggest fucking.
Texas has more women and minority farm
operators in any other state in the
nation.
Texas.
Powerful Texas with diversity.
I love that.
Go down for one second real quick.
Just a little bit.
There's the thing that said America's
biggest ranch goes on sale for 725
million.
Seven.
Click on them.
See how many fucking what is that
fucking place?
Ten thousand acres of land.
One hundred.
Ten thousand.
One hundred and 10,000.
Five hundred and 10,000
acres of bug me.
Seventy 500 cows.
Look at the size of that fucking place.
Five hundred,
10,000
acres.
This is the kind of money that makes fun
of Jay z.
You know,
like in America were like Jay z's rich
are these fucking people are rich.
This is,
this is wealth,
this is pure wealth.
A scroll back up to that building.
That's a look at that old school stone
building on the property.
Know there's,
um,
I,
I have a friend who was in at a ranch in
Texas and they found petroglyphs in a
cave.
What?
Yeah.
Petroglyphs.
Like ancient native American petroglyphs
of an unknown origin.
They don't know who did.
And I was like,
well,
don't they have historians come here and
wrote that off like the.
They got a lot of it here.
It's all over the place.
They don't even pay attention to it.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
They just don't.
They don't bother with it.
Ancient Petroglyphs.
Click on the upper left hand corner.
The one that you just had Mexico.
Is that New Mexico?
Yeah,
they have them all over.
It's all over.
Yeah.
So Arizona,
New Mexico,
Texas,
everywhere that.
The thing is,
no one's like curating them.
No one's taking care of them.
They just exist on this ranch.
And the ranch was a,
was a hunting ranch.
That's awesome.
They took pictures of him.
Where is that?
Jamie?
That's fucking amazing.
My friend.
Steven Rinella.
Who's new show mediator is now only on
Netflix.
It's a hunting show.
It's on Netflix.
Like an intelligent,
really well narrated hunting show.
That's,
that's,
that's done.
And produced by a brilliant guy.
My friend Steven Rinella.
But he was in Guyana,
which was where Jonestown was,
where he fucking killed all those
people.
Jones Koolaid.
Yeah.
And uh,
they found these petroglyphs on a rock
and they were like,
who?
Who made these like no one has any idea.
It's like right by this waterfall.
No one has any idea.
It's a fascinating series.
He's in Guyana,
living with these indigenous people and
fishing in these rivers for like three
days.
And just they,
they just live and it's three,
it's three episodes and they camp out by
this river and use these traditional
methods of hunting that these people
have used for thousands and thousands of
years.
But now they're wearing like,
like under armour tee shirts.
Shit,
they're still barefoot.
It's still.
That's so weird.
It's like this weird toms shoes,
but also don't wear any shoes.
No nothing.
No one wears shoes anyway.
They get all the old shirts and all
that.
So they get clothes from salvation army.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So they're wearing like this,
these,
these things from Western civilization
what?
And like Steve's got like he's got these
modern hoyt bow and they're both fishing
in the river for these things called a
poc who,
which is brilliant.
Red Fish is beautiful.
Red Fish and the whole scene is like so
crazy.
It's like a combination of Western
civilization because they've got like
some western stuff mixed in with this
culture that really hasn't changed that
much and thousands and thousands of
years.
But then they find these petroglyphs
that are by this waterfall and they
don't know.
And he's like,
it was like,
where do you think these came from?
It was like,
we don't know.
Nobody knows.
They say like the calm,
like the ancients,
the ancients wrote it like they don't
even know who the fuck that.
So it could be thousands and thousands
of years old.
That's fucking amazing.
Drew these weird faces by this waterfall
and no one's curating it.
It just is what it is.
It's like really priceless history has
just sitting there
also there where they hang out just
sitting there,
you know?
I mean,
that's Kinda like,
that's Kinda like when I was in Italy,
it's kind of like walking by these
ancient structures and you're like,
that's just like a part of your fucking
life.
That is also strange to me.
Dude.
I was in,
we showed some photos the other day was
in Ravello and there was a church.
No weird.
Yeah,
you were there right after me,
but that's all right.
Yeah.
It was a church that was a thousand
years old that was on top of a church
that was far older.
They don't even know how old that church
was.
There was a glass floor where you could
look under the church and see the
ancient church that's below it.
Oh,
I went to this fucking place.
Yes.
You can look below.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Do it.
This is also.
We went to the catacombs.
Did you go to any of the catacombs?
No.
This shit is fucking.
I wish I could like catacombs in Italy
too.
Yeah man.
I was like,
someone's in France where they have the
skulls and all the shit I'm going to
show you.
I'll show you right now.
This is fucking crazy.
So we went and also online by the way,
when I looked up how to get to them,
a lot of the online posts were like,
this isn't.
This isn't necessarily safe.
What the man,
what?
Wait a minute.
So this isn't safe.
Well,
they were just saying that's fucked.
Why?
What is this?
But we'll describe what we're seeing
here.
Are these standing up?
Yeah.
So they have these skulls are what they
do.
What they do is they,
they,
they reconfigure the bones of the,
of what they think the human was.
You know what they look like and they
put them in cloth and stuff and stand up
against the law.
Go,
go full screen with that.
Let me see.
That is what episode.
We'll look at that one with a flesh on
them.
What's happening there?
The one where your cursor is,
Jamie,
is that hair on his head?
Guy's dead as fuck.
You got more hair than me.
A Buddhist statue with a mummy in it.
No.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
They found this statue and they did an x
ray of it and found that there was
actual skeleton underneath the statue.
Look at this.
The actual statute was a mummy.
So this is in Naples,
Naples.
Those are all skulls and bones.
Isn't that fucked?
What other cities?
Citizens you.
I heard Florence is amazing.
Florence is incredible.
I,
you is cool too.
I liked.
I think southern southern Italy is my
favorite,
but this is,
you see this shit.
Jamie,
southern Italy.
Sicily.
Sicily is my fucking favorite.
That's my absolute.
That's where my family's from.
Know that their own place.
But I mean,
I mean southern Italy,
like places like Naples and stuff like
that.
Like they look down on you because you
have red hair and when you go to Sicily
they spit on me right away.
No,
you don't.
You know,
it was annoying as Santina.
My last name is Santana because my,
my family's from Sicily and they
immediately hear it.
They go Santino and anything.
I'm going to speak Italian and then when
I don't,
they're like annoyed.
Get Mad at you.
They're like,
no,
no.
I went to somewhere better.
Where Marika English.
We made it out English.
I made.
That's why I came back here and gave you
money.
Money.
We also went to see.
That's fucked a dude that hung himself
for sure.
No,
that's a little kid.
Little Dude.
Go to that.
Uh,
this is all in Rome.
I mean category.
They're all over the wall.
That's in Sicily.
Oh,
look on her face at this guy.
What do you want them to?
What do you want me to do?
What do you want from me?
We also went to savannah.
Do you know what's the Voca is?
No where they shot the godfather.
Look at this.
This is fucking incredible,
dude.
We went to this town where they shot the
godfather and so forth.
It must be just a bunch of assholes from
New Jersey.
Wandered around.
Didn't narrow.
It's don corleone here.
Now.
Where do I get some Gaba?
Margo?
Come get a picture of me in front of his
fucking thing.
Come on,
hurry up.
You Fat.
Fuck all lane.
So what was this deal with this story of
the Buddha?
It was in 2015 is when it was.
Oh,
it's too long ago for us to talk about.
Let's pull it up.
What was it like a new discovery.
Oh yeah.
But I,
but it's a thing.
What do they know why they did that?
So what did they do that did put plaster
over it and create A.
No,
if I'm
going to have any more of this 46 year
old,
but it really is nice to,
at this early in the morning to have a
little bit of.
It's a little more ice in that thing
over there.
I don't know.
I might have another one.
One more glass.
Just one more.
I might as well.
I'm more glass to taunt me to sober
October man.
I can't,
I,
I'm,
I'm uh,
I'm excited for the science of the
curious.
So look,
they did an x ray on this Buddha and
they found that there's an actual
skeleton inside.
Holy Shit.
How weird.
How amazing.
It's not surprising that the southeast,
the Southeast Asia is home to countless
ancient Buddha statues,
but one of those statutes contain some
modified monk that has certainly
surprised Mo.
Five monkeys.
Exactly.
Researches the Netherlands meander
medical center Found they placed a 1000
year old chinese buddhist statue inside
of a ct scanner.
Wow.
Contains the body of buddhist master
name.
Hell I you q and leah.
You knew kwan who may have practiced the
tradition of self mummification to reach
his final resting place.
He's like,
fuck that.
I'm wrapping myself out.
YEah,
this motherfucker just went hog whole
hog.
That's a really funny photo range going
into the machine.
So how do you think they turned him into
that statue?
Like what did they.
Would they put over?
His is so hot and so he probably wrapped
himself right.
And then it says the oregon's had been
removed and replaced with paper scraps
printer printed with ancient chinese
characters.
Whoa.
That's so dope.
That's like a horror movie.
Yeah.
Tune in Stephen King.
Okay.
If you were a month at wanting to
achieve enlightenment and be revered as
a living buddha,
self mummification was your brutal
option.
How is it brutal?
Monks in the spiritual path would starve
themselves for almost a decade,
subsisting on water,
seeds and nuts.
Then they'd be sealed inside the statue
and ingest roots,
pine bark and a toxic tree,
sap based,
t for another 1000 days,
eating and breathing through a small
tube.
Eventually death would come and amongst
mummified this manner were said to have
reached enlightenment.
What?
Talk somebody into that.
What the fuck?
All Right,
check it out.
We're going to plug you in this fucking
thing,
bro.
You have to breathe through a tube.
Dude,
you can only.
You could only drink this toxic t that's
going to slowly kill you.
You want to be a god.
You want to see god?
Dude,
do you want to fucking see god for three
years you're goiNg to eat nothing but
seeds and we're going to wrap you and
you're going to breathe through a
fucking tube.
It's going to be ultimate panic.
They starve themselves for almost a
decade.
Where would they piss and shit while
they're in here for a thousand days of
bob?
Come on a little pool.
It would come right out of their mouth.
That's what motherfuckers you.
That's the shit.
That's the glue.
They would stay in the statue and they
would fill up with shit
and went and that's when they die.
That's it.
That would took a thousand days to
gargle on shit until you finally smell
shit up to your nostrils.
You'd have shit right up to the lip of
your nose.
This is an example of self mummification
fact that his organs removed and
replaced the paper suggest that may not
be true.
All right?
So all this.
Oh,
this all this could be bullshit.
It's going to be some dude just assholes
because this is an asshole article.
Toxic t,
the toxic t thing I think is
fascinating.
That's just another mind control way of
them solely killing our people.
Toxic t.
But someone must have probably done that
because like,
no matter what you do,
there's always someone who's willing to
go further,
you know,
um,
they do those ultra marathons,
right where they run like 200 miles.
They're trying to.
Cameron hanes runs $9,
million miles a day,
whereas a marathon a day,
this is a machine.
Crazy fuck.
So,
um,
what they're,
you know,
he was going to do while we're doing all
this sober october fitness challenge,
he was going to try to get more fitness
points in all of us combined.
Probably,
probably,
probably not that hard to be honest.
He could do it easy.
But um,
what they're going to do now is a 500
mile race,
500 fucking miles,
500 miles.
They run stuff.
He runs fast though.
It's all about time though.
He wouldn't,
he'd have to run for six hours a day.
He had to,
when you sit it.
But this is running guys 24 slash seven.
No,
he sang about minutes.
So he had to.
But he runs three hours a day all the
time.
If he's running marathons,
he's not running more than three hour
marathons.
I'd love to know,
do you want three hours a day?
Do you know how many miles you know how
many,
how fast you run?
It's eight or nine miles an hour.
Do you know what it is?
I tell you what.
I wonder if it's eight or nine grand.
His first 100 or no,
when he ran his first $200,
big foot.
200.
The last Couple hours he was running a
seven minute mile.
Do you know what I'm saying?
That is.
Do you know insane it is that 10
minutes?
Is that time at 10 miles an hour?
Pretty much nine and some change,
But just to just understand how insane
it is.
He running for two straight days,
come on to run more than a hundred and
70 miles and then the last two plus
hours,
I think maybe even more.
He probably like.
Well,
it was actually five hours staunch
about.
He's running seven minute miles.
That's fucking insane.
That's bananas.
Yeah.
No,
that's insane.
That's lit.
I run,
I run five miles a day and that's if I,
in my mind are like almost eight minute
miles,
seven minute miles,
it could clip.
That's a good to great.
You kidding me.
Especially when you were anyone that
runs over anyone that's just a casual
runner that runs over two or three
miles.
They their goal usually is a eight to
nine minute miles to keep good pace.
Seven minute miles after you've already
run hundreds of miles,
but that was the point is like there's
always someone who's willing to take to
another place and that's the thing with
these buddhist assholes,
they always wanting to push.
One guy's like,
oh,
you're just going to literally live off
seeds for a decade.
I'm going to do toxic teeth.
I'm going to live off seats for a
decade.
Then I'm going to seal myself in a
fucking statue that I'm going to drink
poison and that I'm going to die.
I'm gonna.
Get my oWn shit.
Why?
Because I want to be enlightened.
I want to get to the tip top buddy.
Enlightened marijuana,
understand suffering at.
The buddhists are like these italian
gangsters.
I want to understand something on the
deepest level possible though.
What you Choke on your own.
I want to choke on my own poop in my own
self rep sarcophagus,
seed eaton tool breathe and fucking
mumbly statue or one of the most iconic
images from the Vietnam war was the self
immolation guy.
Oh shit.
Yeah.
You ever see the video,
man,
that's.
It's that.
Pull up the video of the guy,
the buddhist monk lighting himself on
fire.
It's just sad image.
Well,
the most fucked up thing about it is the
guy didn't even move now.
Yes.
That's stays.
He's in the lotus position and he's
completely engulfed in flame
and he's just staying self-immolation.
That's a weird Bird,
right?
Mla to emulate.
Slow motion.
So they pour the gasoline,
the gasoline on him.
Nineteen 63.
So this was really the start of the war.
The war went on for more than a decade
afterwards,
right?
Yeah,
he was really early.
He's like,
you know what enough.
I'm going to put an end to this.
Imagine if they said to him beforehand,
yo,
dude,
it's not always.
It's not going to work with the war's
going to go on for another 10 years is a
bad idea to stick around.
And if you play your cards right,
you keep wind up inside of statue.
This is like worldstar,
worldstar jesus fucking.
It's just so crazy because the guy's
just sitting there.
I mean covered,
inflames,
not moving a muscle.
It's sucH a,
such a bizarre scene.
like we get them here.
Yeah.
And at this point he realIzes,
oh shit,
I'm dead.
They just falls over.
What a crazy way to die.
So fucking and all the other dudes just
sitting around going,
oh,
I didn't do that.
Yeah,
they're all thinking about lunch.
I was like,
we're not going to eat rice.
What do we have for lunch?
Rice for dinner.
I'm hungry.
Reading rice,
bitch.
I ain't.
That's crazy.
What if the match didn't work the first
few times?
You know,
he was like,
wait,
hold on.
Let's think about this.
Fuck man.
I mean that whole thing is just.
So that's just.
What does that.
What was that picture at the fucking
end?
What is that?
What does it say?
10 superpowers and the mach seven real
life.
I'm.
No,
no,
no.
Well,
there are some monks that can do some
pretty cool athletic shit because they
don't get any pussy and they just eat
nuts and do pushups,
pushups,
nuts,
seeds.
But that was like a thing where like
people would go to train
with the monks to learn come food.
Do they really have depravity of like
releasing?
They can't come amongst.
Can't come.
That's a good question.
I wonder.
I wonder if they come in their parents
accidentaLly.
If they get mad.
Well,
you have to write.
You know that shipped biologically.
It's a detriment if you or if you don't
ejaculate at some point in your life,
you will just naturally leaK.
This is what your teacher told you.
That's a fact.
Look that up.
That's a fucking fact.
You will leak jamie.
Tell them.
Tell them about your thinking about the
tantrum.
People.
Jamie nuts all the time.
Tells us about these.
Another.
Jamie,
are you a nut king thing?
How much do you know a week?
If you had to guess how many times,
oh,
how many times does I agree to as
measurement.
I was like three cups.
How many tablespoons and isn't salted
for four or five nights a week?
Four or five nights a week.
Seems normal first.
Maybe even days a week.
There may be a little bit more.
Maybe get really randy.
Sometimes it's seven nuts.
If you lifted weights,
maybe it's seven.
If I'm.
You know what's so funny?
I get way more horny after running.
Running,
running gets me horny as shit when I'm
done because my body's kind of
exhausted,
so usually I lift,
I lift a little bit and then I run or
vice versa or I'll run in and I'll lift
to finish,
but the running just like,
I think it exhausts my body and then
that just want a bag.
I just.
Yeah,
you might.
I think my testosterone is just like I
got.
I want to not don't amongst the tantric
stuff where they can like do it without
touching anyone kind of thing,
but for sexting,
sting does that shit where he doesn't
see.
He doesn't come in for like nine days.
It's called being a pervert.
Dude.
Stop thinking about that fucking weirdo.
It's like people are doing that.
They're thinking about sex way more than
the average person.
Just fuck no,
I'm just kinda hold it in.
I'm going to have internal orgasms.
I want to have an external.
It's all flooding back into your system.
I hope that's the face.
I hope you go cross eyed when you come
home.
It's like,
and I always make a fish mouth.
imagine if you were a girl,
was perfect in every way,
but when she comes she would go jello
pudding.
Oh,
this is great.
I can't.
I had a girl that I dated,
I won't,
obviously I won't mention who,
but years and years and years ago I
dated a girl in college and she was so
beautiful,
but when she would come it was so
annoying.
Like it was like a.
It was like,
it was so exaggerated that I remember
catching myself in the mirror one time,
giving myself this face as she was
yelling,
I was going.
I was rolling my eyes like,
oh yeah,
but I was also like,
my dick is in fucking like,
don't.
Let's not play the game.
Like it's not so big.
Just come on,
do the regular fucking.
Don't give me this.
Do you think she was faking it or do you
think she was hyperbolizing her orgasms?
I think it was doing that to please you.
I think she thought it was pleasing me.
It was doing the opposite.
It was making me go,
oh my god,
I'm going to show just regular come and
service with this or she starts punching
you.
I just start.
I just start crying.
She's coming.
I'm crying.
Yeah.
You just hold your is exaggerated.
I think that's what porno does.
Porno tricks.
People in porn because porn girls like.
It's like,
no,
that's fucking insane.
Yeah.
Do you ever hear porn?
And then they do that and you just want
to shut it off.
Turn off the volume.
I'm like,
this is absurd.
Yeah,
but then you're going to look at her
face and.
No,
she's making stupid noises.
Yeah,
because it's going to be distracting to.
It's already in there.
You're like,
I can't disassociate.
This always impresses me in porno is
when like a girl is taken like a fucking
12 inch dick like some and they're not
being loud.
Like I'm always like,
this girl is a fucking thug.
What a soldier that she's getting fucked
and she just like,
it's no big deal.
Me.
I like just looking at it.
You're like this.
There's no way that's not painful.
That's a good point about porn though,
right?
It's like people imitate like people
imitate behavior and films like we were
talking about all the guido's and
imitate god father movies and the
soprano's that they imitate it,
they see it,
they want to act like it.
It's exaggerated.
Emulate a lifestyle tHat's the same with
porn.
Sex.
There's got to be a lot of people that
are emulating the sounds and the noises
in the postures and all that stuff.
Like when do you think people started
regular coming in people's faces.
What year?
What year was the first pioneer in porno
that did like a first come shot?
Like in the thirties,
you think people get it in people's
faces are now.
They didn't ever pulled their dick
south.
They didn't know.
They didn't know you could pull out and
the thirties,
that was the name inside people and just
came inside everybody.
Everybody had a baby.
Well,
yeah,
I mean you think about a timeline wise,
like fucking pregnancy at.
Look at the baby boomer generation.
Not one person pulled out.
My mom's one of 10 kids.
Oh yeah man.
Nobody born in the fifties was ever
pulled out.
I mean like everyone.
That's just what you did.
And then disease and then we and then
disease in the seventies and eighties
spawned this idea of condoms and
protection and then people started
learning.
maybe we will just not come inside of
people.
Well,
they say that one of the biggest changes
in culture was female birth control
because finally women had control of
their own reproductive side.
Right?
But what comes with that is that theY
have to take hormones to achieve that.
Yet he fucking up their chemical inside.
Dude,
have you ever heard like what actually
happens to women?
it doesn't just fuck up their chemical
insides,
fuck up their hormonal cycle.
Right?
But it also fucks up their ability to
discern whether someone is compatible
with them
seriously.
Like it fucks up the science of there.
There's,
there's a thing that women get,
like there's a.
Chris ryan was explaining this to me.
There's an actual smell like women can
pheromonal like when they're not on
birth control,
like if they get guys clothes and like
through a smell guys,
clothes,
they can literally,
they are attracted to certain smells and
the men that the smell this way would be
more genetically compatible with them.
So the pheromones literally is the
fairmont.
There's a pheromone blocker with birth
control.
Then that's kinda what it confuses their
system.
Also,
women who are on birth control are much
more attractive attracted apparently to
alpha male type characters and
aggressive men.
Really?
Yeah.
There's something about birth control
that makes them.
They're not sure why their
attractiveness towards alpha males.
Yeah.
They're more attracted to alpha males.
Well that's not really a negative thing
I guess,
but they're more attracted to certain
types of people.
And you gotta think like,
whoa,
what is that?
It's like I'm not a sociologist or a
biologist.
I really wouldn't know what the fuck
would be the cause of that,
but I would think that it would have
something to do with their body wanting
something different than the baby that
they think is inside them because
they're supposed to be pregnant.
Like this is the whole reason why you
can't get pregnant when you were on
birth.
Control is to pregnant.
Right?
So you're walking around constantly in
the state of pregnancy,
so like why would you be more attracted
to alpha males or aggressive men?
God,
look at my brain.
It's like hunting for a why that would
even make sense.
The only thing that would make sense as
you want something even more aggressive
or dominant,
tory or better or pretending what you've
gotten.
Maybe more protective.
Maybe you think maybe it's it goes and
maybe it's just superb nature.
All those nature characteristics of
like,
I'm pregnant,
I need ultimate protection.
I need ultimate aggression,
ultimate strength and like these are
just all natural.
By the way,
all the fucking equality websites is
probably lighten me up for that.
You know what I mean?
go crazy.
well,
I was reading this biologists account of
what's a,
there's a term called hyper gummy that
it's a natural state for women to be
attracted and to seek out men with
higher social status,
higher financial status programming.
Yeah,
and beTter physical specimens.
that's just natural state where they're
always looking for something bigger and
better.
It's just a genetic state and it's not.
It's no one's fault.
I mean,
and women obviously don't have to give
into this,
but as a natural inclination that they
had,
like if the rock is there.
Right.
Here's perfect example.
He's rich and he's handsome,
huge,
friendly,
and is a giant man and he's probably got
a huge hog and you're a woman is
naturally attracted to go towards him.
So am,
I mean,
I know you got a great bit about them,
but this,
this state is.
It's called hyperthermia.
Yeah.
And that what I was reading about was
this woman who had this awful betrayal
of this man and she was the.
The biologist was relating it to the
state of hyperglycemia if they were
doing it in a very scientific sort of
technical way.
Instead of like saying,
look at this slot,
they were saying this is a natural
state.
Totally.
Women gravitate towards certain types of
males,
you know,
and that this is.
But this is not discussed very often,
right?
No,
no,
because.
Well,
eSpecially because now we're bending all
these rules and names and terms and all
this bullshit.
It's like the people.
I think there's such an escapism from
like the true nature of,
of,
of men and women.
People don't want to talk about anymore.
Like it doesn't exist.
The denial of biology.
It's so crazy to me.
Well,
it's almost like this whole fucking
cavenaugh thing and all this shit and I
don't want to even get into all that
fucking said diatribe of nonsense,
but the one thing I will say that I
don't think anybody talks about the
sexual and social psychology of men and
women.
Nobody wants to talk about when you are
developing as a young teen,
especially a boy,
and you're learning about sexuality and
you're confused and embarrassed and
scared and the way that men and women
interact in that year,
in those years from like 12 to 16,
it's insanely unstable because women are
not as a,
not as hormonally aggressive technically
at that time that men are.
Right.
so these men are fucking hormonal freaks
and they want to do things with these
women,
but they're not supposed to kind of.
And it's kind of okay and they don't
know how to do it.
And they're these weird blurred lines of
women want to be accepted in cool.
And they're in their circles.
So,
you know,
it's like when someone hooks up with
someone early on when poop to people
hook up young and it's like,
ooh.
And it's sketchy and weird.
Sometimes the girl gets labeled a slut,
you know what I mean?
For no reason.
It's Like,
oh,
she's like,
I remember there was a girl in my,
when we were what,
um,
juniors and she was dating a senior and
they had had sex.
You're right.
And it Was like,
she's a slut,
she's not a slut,
everybody wants to do this thing,
but there are these weird subset rules,
but every guy that does it,
that's just what we want to do.
But I don't,
we.
There's no explanation over like how we
got to the point of getting comfortable
there because men are just these horny
freaks that don't know what to do with
the thing.
So there are so many blurred lines of
sexuality and relationships at that age.
Nobody wants to talk about it.
Puritan culture and religion are two
things that set women up in this
terrible place where they give into
their hormonal oranges there somehow
tainted.
You know,
I was in high school.
Everybody knew this and I'm sure you
knew this to everybody knew catholic
school girls were the biggest fucking
thing.
First time I had anal catholics will
call a first and second time because
they are,
they're suppressed.
Yes.
There you're making diamonds.
Okay.
You can take in that you're putting it
under a mountain,
at a fucking diamond is going to come
out of,
you know,
I mean,
it's catholic school girls,
right?
And it's all over tHe country.
Where did you grow up in chicago?
Chicago,
columbus catholic school girl.
so I went to catholic school.
So yeah,
talk to us.
Tell us some of them.
Uh,
jay?
Yeah.
Be nice.
What?
They weren't on their jumpers.
Sometimes they had shorts on.
Sometimes they did,
but there was a marked difference
suppression right?
between catholic school girls and
regular girls.
Yep.
Yeah.
Well I mean the public school girls
around me.
Wait,
what is it?
A whole different thing.
So most of them are private school rules
for.
I was at.
So the biggest freak,
the dated during my high school years
was a girl.
It was a wonderful girl,
but she went to an all girl catholic.
Of course she was suppressed completely.
Yup.
So when you hold someone in a cage like
that,
what do you think is gonna happen?
It's like,
of course when they get out they get
wild and go nuts.
Scrub was nuts,
man.
she was wild.
But that's.
So that's what I'm saying no one wants
to talk about.
And again,
I'm not trying to dive into kevin all
bullshit,
but people are young and they do fucking
crazy shit when you are hormonally at
your beginnings and you're confused and
weird.
I mean,
guys know when guys start masturbating.
It's this disgusting,
weird,
secret,
creepy,
gross,
sAd,
like undercover secret that you don't
tell your friends and your pants off.
So and all of that is swirling inside
your head over sexuality.
Then when you do get a chance with a
girl,
it's uncomfortable.
It's awkward.
It's weird.
Again,
not talking about whatever fucking he
did.
I'm just saying you're already in this
weird state of men are fucked up when
they're sexually reaching this new peak
Of their life that they just want to
like jerk off and come and fucking.
And how much information are they
getting from their parents?
Zero.
Almost none.
Almost.
That's the thing.
How much guidance.
So the rule is you don't understand.
And also our society perpetuates if you
want to be real fucking honest.
Our society perpetuates this weird pull
and push of like,
you know,
no,
I don't want,
you know,
that fucking song baby.
It's cold outside,
you know that.
How the christmas song a baby just stay
for a really should go.
It's cold outside.
It's a christmas fucking song.
You know what it is?
Jamie knows what the fuck I'm talking
about.
Yeah,
you do.
Sure.
It's a christmas song and it's called
baby.
It's cold outside.
But christmas song about rape.
So was a hundred percent.
It is.
No,
I'm dead serious here.
He's playing it.
Didn't play it on youtube or will get in
trouble.
Really can't stay is an old to see if I
can find her.
Oh,
so.
I do know the song she sang.
I got to go home.
My parents are going to say the whole
time he's like,
come on,
just have one more drink.
Just to stay out a little bit longer.
He's trying to fucking louver up.
Yes.
And by the way,
terrible staying at the end because she,
she wants to be with him the game.
Right.
So the thing that nobody wants to
fucking talk about at all.
And I'm not.
Again,
I'm not fucking saying anything other
than this is a perpetuation of our
culture.
For a long time of pull and taken teas,
tease is a game that women play and men
play to have like,
you know,
look at it.
I really can't say it's cold outside.
Got to go away this evening.
It has been a so very nice.
My mother will start to worry.
My father will be pacing the floor.
I'd read,
I read.
I read a really better scurry.
Maybe just a half a drink more.
That's her finally admitting the
neighbors might think what you say.
What's in this drink?
Ah,
you're very pushy.
You know,
I like to think of it as opportunistic.
I simply must go.
The answer is no.
The welcome has been so nice and warm.
My sister will be suspicious.
My brother will be there at the door and
my maidens aren't made is vicious.
We'll maybe just a cigarette more so now
she's like,
no,
no.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Oh god.
Okay,
fine.
Another drink then.
That took a lot of convincing.
Okay.
That's the last word that took a lot of
convincing.
Yes.
Oh weird.
So what I'm saying it that shit.
Oh my god.
This got to be the 1,940
forties,
maybe people just rape 50 slash 50 to 50
2:52
now,
but he wasn't the original 44.
My point is this shit has been going on
forever and it's fucking real and nobody
wants nothing to do with the cabinet
thing.
Right,
and here's the thing about the cabinet
thing.
You know what I mean by that?
No,
I didn't know,
but here's the thing.
Even the fact that you have to be
defensive right there.
Everybody has to go.
This is what I'm saying.
What I'm saying.
I'm not supporting rape.
I'm not.
Or even discussing it.
All people are ready to fucking hit you
in the head.
well,
of course there's no conversation to be.
There's a woman who had a brutal take on
it.
A brutal.
There's two ways we can look at this.
There's a woman who had a really brutal
take on this,
leah,
that was on Jordan peterson's a twitter
page.
If you go to Jordan peterson's twitter
page,
there's a woman who is a.
I don't know what she does,
but she talks about how this woman who
was aCcusing brett kavanaugh goes to
this predominantly.
She teaches at this predominantly
women's college,
were 79 percent of the students are
women.
The majority,
the vast majority of the professors are
women and social justice is the number
one thing that they promoted the school
ahead of education of everything.
When you look at the schools like list
of like what it aims to accomplish and
how to educate the students like
promoting social justice is one of the
primary things.
IT's the first one above everything else
and the idea is that why would this
woman risk everything and with this
woman's take is who's criticizing this
is that she's not risking anything.
She's rewarded from this.
Her culture,
this is a big deal and she's very
cynical about this.
She's like,
this woman has no recollection.
Doesn't remember how she got home,
doesn't remember where the party was,
but does remember that someone may have
tried to do something to her.
You know,
I'm noT a big fan of,
of criticizing people who come out and
say someone did something to them or try
to do something because you don't know.
You don't know you're on the outside
looking in and you're,
you're,
you're trying to pick holes in their
story.
I don't even know if they know because I
don't.
I don't.
here it is.
Yeah.
If you click on the video,
you can hear some of what this woman
says like click on it and play some with
this one says we don't have to,
notably by the lifelong friend who
supposedly accompanied blazzy forward
and presumably might have noticed.
It sounds like Jordan Peterson.
Celtic.
I can play that actually probably get
kicked off.
Okay.
But the,
the,
the point is that like there's only two
people that know what really happened
and they don't even know what really
happened.
Well,
you're talking about something that
happened 35 fucking years ago.
I mean if he,
if she said thirtY five years ago,
this guy raped me.
Okay.
That's a different story.
Well,
yeah.
yeah,
but this is not what she's saying.
Right.
What iS she saying?
My.
From what I understood,
and by the way,
this is something I distanced myself
from because I was just.
It was so overwhelming that I was like,
oh god,
that he held her down while the other
dude was in the room and he kind of
helped him held to older down and he had
his penis on her or did he.
Is that what he's saying?
Let's find this because people got super
mad and we talKed about this the other
day,
like you should have done research for.
You discussed a predator.
Might as well.
See,
that's what's impOrtant.
First of all,
I'm not supporting him anyway.
I'm not standing there.
None of the either none of us,
but that's the thing is like when you
talk about it,
someone goes,
what do you.
What are you In favor of him?
Exactly.
The you have to have a conversation
about what's going on.
Otherwise I'm just,
I'm just numb.
This is a giant platform and then if
we're discussing in this giant platform,
we should be informed.
I disagree with that because I think
that we're just having a conversation
about something you just happen to be
privy to this conversation because I'm
not pretending I'm some sort of an
export or that I have some sort of
information that you don't know that if
you have those misconceptions,
let me clear those up right now.
I'm a fucking moron talking to another
more on next to another three more
rounds in this room.
They're all dudes talking.
Okay.
You don't know jack shit.
Nah,
I know what I.
I know.
I know my feeling of the whole thing.
I know the feeling of the whole thing is
that no matter what anybody,
it's kinda like a what got in trouble
for norm.
Norm mcdonald got in trouble no matter
what I think are suffering in a bad,
bad way.
Okay.
Here,
what it says here,
it was sure with the most explosive and
surreal confirmation hearing since
clarence thomas and anita hill in 1991
nominee for the supreme court was asked
if he was a gang rapist and a blackout
drunk while defending himself by
describing how long he preserved his
virginity,
his accuser described him grinding,
covering her mouth,
and fearing that he was accidentally
going to kill me.
Okay,
well that's pretty fucking serious.
So if he was,
if he was covering her mouth Because she
was protesting and he was grinding in
her right?
Some pretty dark shit.
Fuck yeah.
So that,
that's gone down a little bit.
Yeah.
Keep scrolling down please.
I'm Ms.
Hill.
Twenty seven years ago,
dr blazey a psychology professor in
California treated gingerly and the
republicans who feared,
okay,
this is blah blah blah,
blah blah.
But,
but,
but that.
Okay.
So that was a.
She became a very human being,
telling a terrible story about judge
kevin on compelling terms that brought
many women to tiers,
transformed the battle for the supreme
court.
Okay.
Well see that's all I needed to hear.
See that,
that the kind of person.
Now look,
I don't know if he did this,
but if he did do this,
the kind of person that covers a woman's
mouth.
Yeah,
that's crazy shit.
That's an extra level of darkness.
You're not like trying to kiss her and
against each other covering someone's
mouth.
Right?
That's right.
But if he really did that,
yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
If it's all true,
that's what that is.
That's him trying to hold her back from
something.
So,
uh,
Donald Trump said this,
you know,
this famous quote that it's a tough time
for boys.
So girl made a song.
I've heard that song song is actually
very great song.
It's a good song and I'm going to tweet
it,
but I'm like,
when I was about to tweet and my people
are going to get so fucking mad at me,
um,
her name is on twitter,
it's mercedes,
l y n z.
SHe has a beautiful voice and the song
is,
it's a scary time for dues.
Scary time for.
Yeah.
I listened to it a few times.
it's really good.
Maybe we could play a little bit of it.
Can we play a little bit over?
We get kicked off of youtube now.
Jamie's just shaking and shaking his
fucking head.
Just that it would get tagged because
I'm sure she's trying to monetize.
She's probably got a billion views.
So anyway,
her twitter page.
Listen,
this is the thing.
Men in particular,
you're going to hear this.
You go,
oh,
you fucking support news every time,
man.
Fucking male bashing shit.
Give me just give me a little volume.
I can't go to chaperone.
I can't wait.
The only one I own.
Yeah.
Look,
it's.
She's just going on about how difficult
it is to be a girl and when you're not a
girl,
it's not something you consider and so
all these guys
truth.
She's like,
I can't live on the first floor.
I can't just leave my window open at
night.
Like all these things are fucking very,
very true.
It's a good song and she's got a great
voice.
Listen,
this is the.
This is the whole thing that I think
we're.
We're talking about.
You're allowed to see to see truth on
all sides of all of these issues.
I don't think you ever have to be so
staunch about anything.
I disagree with people that are so
staunch about just being like,
this is the end of the discussion.
You're only this way or not.
It's like,
no man,
I don't know all the stories.
I don't know all the truths of,
of the cabin.
All bullshit.
I don't know all the truths of anything
that woman coming forward.
I tend to believe a woman that's gonna
go out of her way.
I don't think she's looking for fame.
I don't think any of the girls that came
out from louis,
we're looking for fame and attention to
one wants attention to have their name
googled and come up with this for the
rest of their life.
So I wouldn't say that.
I see.
I don't,
I wouldn't say no one.
I think most people don't want that kind
of.
Okay.
We don't know what,
you know.
Okay.
You know,
who doesn't want that kind of attention?
The psychopaths.
But the donald truMp,
uh,
what's her name?
The fucking porch talking.
Okay.
Yeah,
I think she all she wanted was
attention.
I'm sorry.
I'm like,
well,
she thought the guy consensually and all
she did was make fun of his penis.
Like she wants money.
Yeah,
no shit.
Okay.
He's making money from it and she's in
her forties and she's still stripping.
It's fucking sad.
It's not like a zelda when Dr.
Ford and these other women,
they're not doing it for the fucking
attend.
They don't.
She doesn't want.
She's doing that because there is a
truth in there of what happened and I
believe that.
I don't know what it is,
but I believe there's something fucked
up that went down and unfortunately we
are in the middle of this.
What,
what can be done?
Who,
who knows?
How do we.
There is no physical evidence or rape or
gray area,
like what am I supposed to do?
This offices,
this deep understanding of the flaws of
the human memory.
Both his and her.
Totally.
When you're dealing with 35 years ago,
if you tried to ask me,
you know,
what happened when you and this girl
will make it out in the backseat of a
car 35 years ago.
Good luck.
I,
I don't know if this is a few moments.
I remember.
I don't know.
It was me and it was amazing by that.
I don't fucking know have to remember
like very few sexual encounters from
high school,
but I remember my girlfriend,
but I know that was consensual.
Yes,
they're all central girlfriend gave me a
blowjob on the porch and I came so hard
in my ears rang and it's never happened.
Never happened since.
Peaked when I was 16 years old.
I'm not.
It's so hard.
It was like literally my you remember
doesn't blow job you've ever had.
I wasn't beating off back then.
I was,
I actually had sex before I jerked off.
Shut the fuck up.
Real id.
Yeah,
I did.
And it's not like I had sex real young
either.
How old were you when you,
when you first thought?
I think I was 16.
How old were you,
jamie?
nine.
Fuck machine,
he's it.
I'm looking at it with a nut case.
That cancer next shirt.
Not king in catholic school.
Just lifting up skirts and just send
that at home.
Oh,
biggest dick over at st peter's.
That's right.
No,
seriously.
How old were you?
Do you know?
17.
16,
That's right.
That's the average ages man with biggest
guys balls.
That's the real nutcase.
Poor bastard.
There's a bunch of those guys to get
elephant titus.
Have the balls.
I guess they just don't want to get
their balls cut off.
That looks like a halloween costume to
say.
But there's some,
some men who really do have those,
but luckily that guy,
that guy's naked.
That's a sack.
Wait a minute.
So take me you fuck before you ever
joked on.
Yeah,
I did.
And,
and,
and so then when you jerked off,
which I don't recommend because I had
zero control,
just going to say we stuck it in,
be like,
yikes.
I mean,
I've,
I,
the first time I had sex without,
without like raw without a condom was,
was my brain was like,
all right,
there's a strategy to this.
You've got to be able to last look out
the window.
The moment it was just like,
yeah.
The first time I ever orgasm was a girl
jerking me off.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Well I guess mine was gene's robin.
Mine was a dry humping.
Jamie,
you did a bunch of that shit.
You dry hump from dry humping.
I probably had like a little bit my
underwear,
you know,
like I used to have a bit about that.
Like,
like you ever take your underwear off
and this is a stream of sperm that
somehow or other from the tip of your
dick to your underwear.
Like,
what the fuck is this?
I go,
that's those green baret sperm deliver
on the tip of your dick with a knife in
their mouth.
I don't give a fuck about your plans for
the future.
Those are the ones that get people
pregnant because they just wanted to go
ready to go get the underwear.
Fuck pussy.
Let's go there.
Over zealous,
zealous,
they hit that underwear because
sometimes you find pre-cum in your
underwear.
You're like,
what is this?
What's happening here?
Pre-cum is the strongest come.
That is the.
That is the most potent.
Yeah,
that's the most potent savages.
The hordes,
barbarian hordes,
fucking swords and shit.
Pre-cum is the,
what is it?
The green berets or whatever like that
because my regular comments like the
navy reserves?
Yeah,
like coast guard.
They might come out.
You guys got to make it.
Not the disrespect that coast guard
blank you boys,
but yeah man.
I mean I didn't get any birds and the
bees talk.
Did you watch?
Not even remotely.
What the fuck?
Parents?
No fucking way was trying to think.
I don't think they even really did it in
school.
Maybe just like student teachers.
I didn't get shit.
Do you want to know when I got my.
This is my father embarrassed the shit
out of me.
I don't know if I've told this on this
thing,
but the most embarrassing thing my
father did to me.
We were eating dinner when I first
started jerking off and figuring it out
and shit.
You know,
my dad at dinner in front of my whole,
my family,
my dad was like,
you've been spending a lot of time in
the bathroom,
and my mom was like,
hey,
stop it.
And I was like,
these motherfuckers had been talking
about me.
They know I'm jerking off and they've
had multiple conversations.
I know it must be whacking off again,
that little fucking horn ball because I
would,
I would lock the door and go in the
bathroom.
I got a stomach ache if my mother ever
said to embarrass you,
you,
oh my god.
In front of my fucking inside my sisters
there.
I was like,
oh my god.
And my mom was like,
hey,
like that.
And my dad was like,
oh no,
nothing,
nothing.
And I just knew it was him taking that.
You know what it was now as a man,
like I know that to my son.
I'll take a shot like that too.
It was just a guy shooting.
But you would tell your son.
I know,
but I would shit on them a little bit
too because that was funny.
It was funny.
It was very funny.
In retrospect it was like,
like he bought me a kathy Ireland
poster.
Do you remember kathy Ireland?
He bought me a kathy Ireland poster and
he was like,
don't.
And he said something along the lines of
like,
a don't let this get stuck together.
And I was like,
ooh,
but I know he's just a fucking jerk off
out in your room with kathy Ireland
posts.
Well,
because I used to love her.
I thought she was gorgeous.
She's still one of those chicks.
It's hanging
in there and like she was my.
She was my ultimate favorite supermodel.
She's like 180 years old now.
She's.
How old is she now?
Fifty five.
Kathy Ireland today.
Let's see what you look.
Sorry.
Still beautiful.
Wait a minute.
Is that real?
She looks that good.
Jesus christ.
What kind of genetics does she have?
Is that a recent image?
Looks reasonable.
Come on.
Five,
10.
That's.
I love kathy Ireland.
Kathy and I remember louisville's still
gorgeous.
She's beautiful.
Will you go back to her when she's
young?
Jamie will pull up an image and when she
was like at her feet when she was like
her,
kathy Ireland that I remember when I was
a kid was super hot.
No,
those aren't it.
That's her age.
You googled 90 look at that.
Oh yeah.
She was fucking unbelievable.
Through google.
Kathy Ireland.
Two thousand 18.
God dog is my favorite dude.
Google,
kathy Ireland.
Two thousand 18.
And see what she looks like now.
That was a.
That was a video.
I play it over.
That's real.
That was the scene where you just play?
Yeah.
That was New York stock exchange.
She's a gimme.
Go to images.
Let's see.
That second one is that we're here with
the red.
The one above that with the cleveland.
That's insane.
She's fucking gorgeous.
Congratulations,
lady photographer.
she punched a photographer.
Click on that.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I love her even more.
She just got moxie because they're
fucking annoying.
Punched a photographer at age 17 after
he crossed the line.
Oh good.
She's knocked him the fuck out.
That,
by the way,
is the ultimate creepo move.
Shit.
I knew a dude who was a photographer.
Yup.
I'm using air quotes because really it
was a weed dealer and he also took hold
in photography would do it for girls who
wanted to air quotes again.
Model.
Yeah.
Right.
And he would help them,
but he was just.
He would tell me,
yeah.
He goes,
you get them alone.
And the first time he take pictures with
him,
he barely talked to them.
You ignore them and then after awhile
you say,
come on,
you gotta give me more.
You gotta show me more.
And the next thing you know,
you're banging them.
These are rapists by the way.
These are like sort of like a planned
rape.
It was rape and anybody fucking sicko
that figured out a way to get girls
turned up like they wanted,
manipulate them on and they buy him,
ignoring them.
This was his move.
The date,
the move was,
you take pictures of them the first time
and you totally ignore them and don't
even pay attention.
I just take pictures of them like it's
no big deal.
Okay.
Please try something else.
Um,
stick your legs in different,
like put your foot back there.
That's it.
Okay,
look towards me.
great.
Okay,
And then there was no.
Wow,
you are so beautiful.
There was nothing.
there was nothing,
nothing.
You give them nothing.
and then then give them a little the
second time and then he would start and
he would take pictures with them for
free because they all had no money but
they wanted photos and you want to be
models and he had good cameras,
sold weed.
So hE had a lot of money.
I don't know how difficult photography
is.
You do have.
It's difficult for
sure.
Yeah.
Well to be good at it.
It's.
Yeah.
What's the name of the creepo dude?
Terry,
what's his fucking name?
That guy that he got in trouble,
right.
He did like,
um.
Is that it?
yeah,
he,
he got in trouble for,
for being a creep and he was the kind of
guy.
All those photos he took of like,
you know,
well apparently it was a giant hog.
He have girls like jerk them off.
Girls tug them molly.
Yeah.
This fucking guy.
And right.
Didn't you end up getting in trouble
for.
Yeah.
He ended up getting an of trouble.
You have a look at this fucking guy.
Look at him.
He looked and when someone says,
what is a creep look,
look,
I go,
yeah,
like a fucking three quarter balding
glasses weirdo with a strange mustache
or mutton chops.
It's this guy for sure.
What's that?
We missed something with a net worth of
$350.
million dollars.
Can he makes an additional
$2,000,000,000
off of retail empire?
dude,
she's a gangster according to a profile
on forbes magazine,
which means that Ireland has even
surpassed rumored billionaire Jessica
Simpson and revenue.
Damn jessica simpson's a billionaire.
So sam from,
uh,
from,
from her,
from makeup and clothing and shit.
Yeah,
she's a genius.
Heard was often blowjobs.
Yeah.
You suck a billion to a billion bucks.
Imagine damn billionaire.
That's,
that's crazy.
I should.
thousand million,
I should say kathy Ireland.
Slide into my dms.
Please come on.
Fucking billionaire mega.
I'll that photographer you punched and
I'll finish the fucking job.
Job alive.
Crushes.
Break his ribs.
All of them.
It's fucking.
Imagine walking around with broken ribs.
I broke two ribs.
Planful,
playing football and I'll never forget
the pain of that.
I'd rather I'd rather break any other
bone than a rib.
Again,
you can't.
You can't inhale.
You like you can inhale and then when
you sit down and you're like in pain.
I hated ribs.
Broken arm,
a ankle collar,
bone,
ribs to collarbones.
Rough one.
Collarbone.
Fucking sucks.
My brother in law had a metal plate put
in his shoulder because his collar bone
was shattered in a motorcycle and I was
just going to say it's either like
motorcycles or skiing or like any,
any anything where you're going over 30
miles an hour slam.
That's the only Way to break a
collarbone.
There is no other way to fake
Yeah,
because he.
Because he got hit by a car or
motorcycle crash.
Why?
I'm saying,
oh,
he wiped ouT.
Wiped out.
I saw dude.
I saw a guy get hit the other day and it
made my.
Made my heart hurt for the cake.
Yeah,
he got smoked.
I watched it.
I watched it happen.
He was key.
Was going left through an intersection.
A guy ran the yellow.
He was really running a red,
it was red,
you know what I mean,
and,
and he slammed on the brakes and the car
turned a little bit and the bike and he
tried to like jerk the bike as hard as
he could,
button boom.
And it made my,
he was alive,
but I was just like,
oh,
probably broken.
Oh,
he was tall dude.
He couldn't,
he didn't move.
I mean,
fuck yeah.
Motorcycles are so scared.
The shit out of red light this morning
and the light turned green and some dude
just whizzed
in between me and some guy who was about
to change lanes.
So like I'm in this lane and I'm driving
straight and this guy Was about to
change lanes.
this guy went and I went,
oh,
inches away.
I almost saw death.
I saw a guy get killed and that happens
all day every day in la because they're
allowed to cut lanes.
But here's the thing.
Risk.
Yeah.
Yup.
In that thing where you're cutting lanes
and the guy turns into you and kills
you,
it's their fault.
It's on you.
It's crazy.
Like in chicago,
you can't split lanes in Illinois you're
not allowed to shit and peel,
but there's no helmet law.
I seen that,
which to me is like the most chicago and
his shit.
So all these fucking guys on harleys.
Fucking helmets with their feet up on
the things not wearing a helmet.
I'm not some,
not some faggy.
Dual did pushing scared of head trauma.
They should just all be forced to look
at gary busey before and after.
You don't want to wear a fucking helmet.
Did him in.
I know you know he hit a curb with his
skull.
He's alive is insane.
Oh,
the doctors.
Yeah.
Dr this shit.
I just smothered him with a pillow.
You're good.
We're gonna take you poor bastard.
I was watching something the other day
with him.
Joe really recently talking and I was
like,
whoa,
we're here on rogan.
Joe.
I fucking love you man.
He's fucking great bubble of having
normal talk.
Yeah,
it's all like theatrical and animated
because I think years of I think years
of of acting and stuff late in his brain
and now that he's kinda like,
he's off the edge,
I think he feels like he has to be a
caricature to like feel normal.
Right.
You know what I mean?
I think he's,
thAt's the way he masks the serious
brain trauma and pain,
whatever pain is really going on.
I think that's it.
Maybe it's fine.
Maybe a medium and it's like,
hey,
I'm playing it up.
This is what I got.
He said,
what do you mean?
This is a bit my thing.
He's outside smoking a cigarette.
He goes,
what are you talking about?
Is a fucking bit.
It's just me doing fucking try and make
a living.
Just making money,
man.
I'm trying to feel my fucking family.
Wait,
fuck is wrong with you.
So I got one.
I was like two inches higher than the
other one.
That's what he's gotten out above his
eyebrow.
It's like where I broke should be.
It's like way up here.
Well,
his goal,
god caved in and it was not funny to
laugh at,
but my god,
it just,
he just looks when you see him,
when he's young,
you know,
he's kinda like a normal looking dude
and like,
okay,
looking dude,
and then now you're like jesus christ
and he's just all squirrely now.
But if you go back to him and like
lethal weapon,
he was a bad motherfucker.
Look,
look at his left eyes down like shifted.
Something's Wrong.
Yeah.
But when he was young,
like the lethal weapon,
like when he played mr joshua to fucking
wicked and I was awesome.
I go to that one picture with the two
heads.
Scroll,
scroll down please.
Photoshop.
Go to the one picture with the green
lettering.
Photoshop.
Oh yeah.
Don't go to that after rude.
That's just being rude.
Being asked about the one the right hand
side with the suit suit on deloitte.
Below that with the suit.
The actual suit right there.
Yeah.
That's a real photo player.
Just being silly.
Well,
this was back when helmet laws didn't
exist.
Yeah,
no helmet law.
You could ride around la with no helmet,
but they should.
I mean,
even if there wasn't a law,
why wouldn't you want to mean fuck me?
I,
I get that.
It's probably why I don't listen to all
the community is like,
you don't get it bro.
You don't understand freedom.
I liked my fucking brain busey.
Yeah.
I liked my.
I liked my brain.
Sorry man.
I don't know.
But there's states.
Arizona is another one you see people
with no.
Hell no.
Helmet law.
Yeah.
No helmet.
Texas.
I think vegas you allowed to have in
Nevada.
I mean I've seen plenty of guys on bikes
without one,
but I can't tell you who.
What cop would pull you over.
You know what I mean?
Kind of like in vegas.
What do theY do?
The last thing on their fucking mind are
supposed to.
In vegas you are.
Look up just google states without
helmet laws and see how many there are.
I Colorado,
I know you don't have to have one.
Definitely the wild country man,
that's.
They don't give a fuck.
Nope.
It's square state.
Squarespace.
Perfectly square medal in 19 states that
require it.
Wow.
In three.
One,
there is no motorcycle helmet.
Use law in three states,
Illinois,
Iowa,
and New Hampshire.
but says currently 19 states and the ndc
have laws requiring all writers,
all writers,
both past 19 states.
All riders.
Yeah,
but three states have no laws in
Illinois,
but what?
But some states.
Wait a minute.
It's only three states where you can
wear no helmet.
One of those states,
Illinois,
Iowa and New Hampshire bleed image or
Colorado.
Maybe it's maybe it's maybe the law.
It's new.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Is it just google helmet laws in
Colorado motorcycle.
I've seen people ride motorcycles in
Colorado with no helmet.
Helmets are proven to save lives in
Colorado.
However,
if the motorcycle operator passengers
are under 18,
they must wear a helmet.
Passengers,
passenger law,
but that's not the under 18.
Uh,
if they're over 18,
they can Do whatever the fuck they want.
Is that what it says?
It says,
so there isn't a helmet law.
You just,
if you're,
if you're 18 or if you're 60 minutes,
they have helmet laws.
So what you're saying is three states
have no helmet laws.
That means under 18,
over eight doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Right?
But some states have laws,
but grown ass adults can decide to go
suicide.
They won't style and yeah,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
That's fucking crazy weird that people
would fight for that.
They don't like saying no seatbelt law.
That's the crazy thing.
What do you don't.
You don't want to wear it.
But here's the thing,
like how is it okay to ride a
motorcycle?
Ever?
And I have to have a seatbelt on.
Yeah.
Like I'm inside a metal cage.
That's it.
Motherfuckers that is a $3,500
pound cake.
It was steering wheel and this
motherfuckers just got handlebars.
He can go flying.
I don't get that shit.
I don't know why you wouldn't want to
fucking wear a helmet.
There's no.
There's nothing to hold you on.
You're fucked.
You get clipped.
You're done.
We're going to come into a time within
the next 20 years,
we're automated.
Cars are going to be the norm and you're
not going to be allowed to drive.
There's going to be states where you're
not allowed to drive yourself,
but,
but what you just said it was right.
There will be states that will
absolutely fight against that to make
sure people can still drive.
Fucking do whatever the fuck we want.
Yes.
Hello,
mr tesla.
Man.
Listen here.
Ilan mirsky.
I saw you smoked pot on rhogam.
You don't know what the fuck you're
talking about.
Rotten out from the inside.
Shooting dildos into space on it.
What the fuck to ilan fucking shady
motherfucker.
One of my favorite conspiracy theories
with the.
Whether there's an actual man that like
fucked elan's wife that was in the suit
of the space.
Imagine space.
Yeah.
Hey,
duct tapes.
Your mouth is,
traps you into a rocket,
launches you into space.
He gives you oxygen for like five days.
That would be the most.
I'm going to let you see space,
but then you're gonna fucking die.
You're gonna.
Die slow burning nuts and poisoned t and
a little tube debris,
but when you shit yourself,
you will die in this space.
There's a guy in that suit that's a
great conspiracy.
Imagine what a fucking psychopath you
have to be to launch a car that you made
in this space like that.
Can I tell you something?
That's dope car.
I think that's the coolest fucking thing
anybody's ever done in space is some
shit into space.
That's an artifact.
It's an artifact for someone to find
you.
Imagine if you're an alien race and
you're flying by like we're going to go
to earth.
We spotted something.
What?
It seems to be some sort of vehicle.
Someone's coming towards us,
signaling him shit and nuts and poison
in it.
Dope car.
That's a fucking awesome looking car
too.
Imagine send that thing in this space.
you saw the tesla.
You saw the tesla roadster,
huh?
When that thing comes out?
No,
he didn't.
he didn't bring it here.
No,
no he didn't.
No he didn't.
No,
it doesn't come out until 2020,
but I thought he has.
Yeah,
he didn't bring it.
That was it.
That was his thought.
He had another one.
I thought he.
I thought he still got sure ms dot but
wait,
but right now it's the fastest
production vehicle ever made,
right?
Yeah.
Zero to 60 in one.
One point six and one point one point
six,
six.
Something insane like that.
The word should be absurd.
That's an absurd.
To go that fast.
if you ever driven a tesla,
dude,
I've been in a pd.
The pd 100.
The ludicrous mode.
yeah.
It's insane.
Too fast.
It's weird.
I would.
I would die in that car,
but it's weird how fast it.
It's,
it's,
it's sillY.
My cars.
Five hundred 10 horses.
That's fast.
When your car is,
get that rumble.
Oh,
well I love engines,
man.
I don't think I'll ever give up engines.
You know.
My buddy said,
he goes,
it sounds like a fucking boat.
I go,
it does sound like a boat.
When I was a kid,
I remember sitting outside on the lake
of hearing people's boats.
I like engines have alwaYs been an
engine guy.
I'm a guy.
Drink.
I can't have one poor little more and
have one for you.
I'll have one for jellies.
Have one for me.
I got to do two hours of courses for
christ and have a heart attack,
I should say.
I love birds so much.
I love everybody in the competition.
I just don't like the fact that bird is
on these medications that could.
All of these health problems could be
completely resolved if you just didn't
drink so much.
Like to take medication so that you can
drink.
It's not Good,
you know?
I mean,
I haD this conversation a long time ago
with anthony bourdain.
He was on statens and he decided to take
statens because he liked to eat and I
don't know what it's good for.
People that have,
um,
it's,
it was that high blood pressure or high
cholesterol,
what is stands for.
He had obviously he was drinking
constantly and he was traveling
constantly and he wasn't exercising
cholesterol and he had had some health
issues and so they put them on these
statens and he started doing brazilian
jujitsu and we started doing brazilian
jujitsu.
He lost a shitload of weight,
changed his diet,
radically cut back on drinking and got
off the statens.
But statens have siGnificant health
risks attached to them.
It's not as simple as they just lower
your cholesterol.
They also do a lot of wonky shit to your
whole system,
to your mental.
Uh,
I don't.
I don't know about mental gracie.
Right?
Well,
he trained with henzel gracie in New
York city.
The hands henzel great piece on it
somewhere.
One of the best gyms in the world.
I know I'm jumping backwards,
but you mentioned something that now
clicked into my head with the mediator
show that your friend does steve when
he.
I think there was a show.
I think there was a clip I just saw
online of him using rendering bear fat
to cook bear.
I just had watched that.
I thought that was fucking amazing
because he was like,
I mean,
I've never,
I'd never heard of that before.
That you can,
you can boil down the bear fat to use as
oil to cook the rest of the meat because
he's saying it was so rich that it was
almost like you could fry neat in it.
He did fry me to fucking blind people.
Have you been using bear fat for ages?
For lard to cook pies?
And he was actually talking about on a
podcast recently that he has a great
podcast as well called mediator,
same name.
And uh,
on the podcast they were discussing how
a fat was used.
That's him there at the rendering this
bear fat.
This is a particularly interesting
episode because this was all about bears
who eat blueberries.
So all that fat had a purple tone to it,
a purple hue to it because the bears had
been,
they had been subsisting on blueberries.
So they tasted like blueberries.
Blueberry fat was supposed to be fucking
incredible and you render it down and
make lard out of it.
And that lord is good literally for
years and use it for cooking and for all
kinds of things afterwards.
But bear lard,
like I have my good friends,
john and jen rivet who,
uh,
live in alberta and they run a bear
hunting operation up there and they bear
all the time and they render bear fat
into these jars of bear lard.
I want to have you cook.
It's fucking delicious in Canada.
Next week,
tell them to come see me in where,
where are you in calgary?
oh,
that's close to them.
I'll tell them to come see you because
they're.
They're lovely people.
I fucking burn as great country up
there,
man.
People and code.
A full man and some of the night is one
of the most beautiful places I've ever
visited in my life.
I haven't been to the national forest up
there.
She'll go do a picture of lake louise to
be a m.
F is bad ass mother fucker be a n.
F,
f.
Banff was not the same thing.
Now it's not the same,
but it is bad as fuck.
It's dope.
It's.
It's different in that we don't use
negatives.
Divine.
Don't use negative.
It's divine.
Divine.
Look at that fucking place that's in
banff.
National forest.
God damn.
Look at that.
Oh,
Canada is that.
There's really a hotel right there on
the water.
That's looks like a fucking disgrace.
Doesn't that look like an eyesore?
God damn hotel,
wouldn't they though?
People are gross,
but how beautiful.
Look at how fucking gorgeous lake
louise's looks.
Fake.
That's what I said the first time I went
there I go phony.
This looks like a guy made it on a
studio like a girl has like photoshop.
When you ever see girls,
when they put that filter on their face
where they don't even look like a real
thing.
Like we need to filter why?
Whoever invented that tricking.
You know,
it's so fun.
What's even grosser guys who use that?
Well,
come on.
Nobody.
I know.
I know a guy.
Selfies with face filter and you look at
it,
you're like,
what in the fuck am I seeing here?
Is everything okay?
Are you doing with your face match your
grandfather.
So fuck happened to your faith.
Fought in Korea so you could fuck with
you face to a gun.
Damn cartoon.
You're animated and yourself.
but that looks like it's photoshop.
So press In.
that was.
That was the first time in alberta that
I saw a moose.
I'd never seen a moose live before.
Crazy.
Didn't.
I went there and I was like,
holy shit,
what is the size?
It's a size of one of those dump trucks
they in,
in dig sites,
you know there's like the where the
wheels are five feet high.
It was like,
get out of here.
I was going to fuck me up.
That thing runs afternoon start
stomping.
Yeah,
and they're late in their strides are
like 10 feet long.
I just had no idea.
I guess as a kid we didn't.
I never saw the,
the only animals like that I saw were
either deer or a.
The only four legged thing I would see
in the wild was so dear as a kid in the
woods about this.
Look at the elc that's on the wall.
Right.
That's an enormous animal.
Yeah.
Like,
look at the size of the antlers.
Yeah.
It's huge.
Uh,
moves is twice that door.
It's got doors by a moose,
weiss that.
But yeah,
that was thing for 2000 pound first time
I saw buffalo.
Same way in Colorado.
I'd never seen before.
I mean in chicago,
like only when you go to the forest
preserve,
so the lakes do you get to see deer and
other than that you're like,
that's it.
I mean There's nothing else in Illinois.
How many people do you think every year
get fucked up by a buffalo in
yellowstone?
Probably at least a couple of idiots.
What boston dynamics just released a new
video and it's scary.
What these fucking freaks.
They want to kill.
Oh my god.
It's jumping over logs.
It's got no wires now.
Now they've.
Oh my god.
Do park whore.
It's doing park core,
hardcore par core boston dynamics.
Look at it.
Jump from box to box.
You guys cut it the fuck.
I don't know.
A lot of people who couldn't do with
that robot.
Just do like most people you know.
Can't do what that robot just did.
I would say that's the majority of the
country.
Could never do that.
That's insane.
Play that one more time.
Yeah.
What is the name of the videos for
people that are just listening to those
core hardcore atlas?
Is that the name of the robot atlas?
That's the one that's gonna kill us all,
but he's got a battery pack on.
Look at him just bouncing around like
it's nothing.
You knoW?
They had some.
They released some voice recognition
from him and he was like,
I want to.
I want to murder everyone.
Most when I stop people coming on eggs,
I'm a big fan of joe rogan.
Joe,
I think you would the best.
I won't rip your cock off.
Ha ha,
ha,
ha ha.
You imagined that fucking machine face
to face to you.
Like I actually enjoy you as a person.
I won't kill you.
It's going to happen.
They're going to keep doing it.
We're fucked.
When I was doing my cardio yesterday,
I was watching x mokena.
Hm.
That's a great fucking movie.
One of my all time favorites.
I literally watched that movie at least
five times.
Scares me,
but I also am in love with it.
I love it,
but when I'm watching that movie,
I'm like,
how far away is this?
A couple years i.
It's got to be less.
I think 10 years.
I think maybe a decade is when we'll
have that,
but when they look like that that good.
Have you seen some of the fucking molds
that they've already had now?
Have you ever seen some of these,
these,
these.
Like the molds that they can make now to
make look real already is scary to me.
There's a bunch of people protesting in
houston because they were about to open
up the first robot sex brothel.
Wow.
That's really interesting.
I don't think that's going to do much
business.
Who wants a nut?
Some robot that somebody else already.
Nut and then two.
I dunno dude.
A lot.
I don't know about in the United States,
but I think in overseas,
I think fucking like japanese.
Love that they love coming and we will
Both go to fucking robots.
How much do you get paid to put the
cleaner?
The robot Cleaner?
Just like dead fish loads.
Washout.
Portal for you?
Load.
Smell like dead fish.
When they sit in your underwear and
steam up just hangs out for a while.
Yeah.
if you jerk off and you don't clean up,
you just let it go.
Whoa.
What is this sex brothel in houston?
That's the ones that actually opened.
Now there's still discussion,
but this,
this here says that by 20,
20 it will be in houston and nine other
cities.
Now,
dId that guy make that sex or is he
going to fuck it?
He made it any fucking.
what do you think?
If you had to guess,
I think for sure that's his wife.
Here's the thing about the sex robots.
Do you think that anybody is going to
make a sex robot that looks like your
average gal?
No.
Yo.
Yeah.
Well,
next year.
Like the next door type of girl.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No.
Well,
well,
how many of them are going to look like
this girl right here,
the exaggerated features.
Ninety percent of them will look like
that.
At least will a girls looked like that
now anyway,
you see girls on the internet,
they all look phony ass shit.
Everyone wants to have the same lips
button thing.
Every girl on the internet now it looks
phony ass shit.
No one looks like a chicken anymore.
But what is,
um,
what is the future going to be for like
when,
when it's not a human and you can do
whatever you want with it,
that's when you're going to find out
what people really are attracted to.
It's exactly right.
You're going to find out the real sexual
psychology of humans.
When we find out that there is no rules
with these things.
Save all your male feminisT nonsense.
I just live real women with
birkenstocks.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
What do you fucking.
When you go to the brothel,
what are you ordering up on your amazon
sex robot?
Chia seeds.
Look at that.
How weird.
What is happening here?
So here's my biggest curiosity.
wait a minute,
mr.
You can fuck a dude.
Fuck one of them.
I was going to get,
get a uh,
you know,
they have those um,
uh,
what are those real dolls?
they have mail,
real dolls.
I was going to get a mail.
Real doll with no debt and no butthole,
no mouth hole either.
Just for jujitsu.
And I was like,
listen,
you send me one,
I don't want anything I can fuck and
fuck up.
And they're like,
sure sir.
We've heard this before.
I'm going to put three bottles.
We're going to have,
we're going to put a bundle on its side
going to butthole and its forehead.
I just don't see a business.
I see a business for them creating
personal sex robots for sure.
Have a niche,
niche market.
I got to tell you,
I know this has always been a big hype
for the past couple of years of like sex
robot,
sex robots and people are like,
what?
It's going to be the end.
IT's like now people are always gonna
want to fuck people.
You want to have reciprocation of
something.
There's gotta be some kind of
reciprocation,
you know?
Do you want to fuck a dead thing?
But also it's like,
it's like real feely almost.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Well it's also,
you know,
there's no emotions there.
IT's going to be like playing a video
game on god mode,
right?
You,
yeah.
You're flawless.
toronto's first sex doll broth has been
open for a year.
How are they doing the same company
that's already been open there,
but how are they doing?
Fine.
Is iT,
is it working?
That's my curiosity.
What's the success rate of a place like
this?
Why does this gross me out?
Kinky slots called halls,
so I couldn't read kinky as adults only.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let me get in there.
I love that you have to click.
Are you an adult yet?
I'm going to adult sure.
Rent,
before you buy rent,
before you buy fake.
I have a loan out system of vaginas.
Look how they all look like.
Don't any of them look like a secretary?
No.
All of them look like some super.
Whoa.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
like isn't there one?
don't have like a starbucks barista
option on.
She's kind of attractive and she's cute.
She's 3,200.
Look at it.
Tid ties by body.
Heat or voice.
Wait a minute.
Is that what it costs to buy?
Thirty $200.
Only 3,200
bucks.
Jamie.
Get one in here.
But let me see what photos look like so
we can order one.
Order one.
How many people would be furious at us
if we had one sitting behind me during
the show?
you would just cut another camera.
Would cut over there to her.
I'll look at it.
That's gross.
Go to that one when she's lying down.
And it looks so weird.
The one that you had just before?
No.
The one with her.
Her tits up in the air.
These bizarre photos.
Man.
That one.
But what's that?
Panic.
She looks fucking.
This is awful.
Stop fucking me please.
Boobs are awful.
Yeah,
it looks good.
That's wack.
It's garbage.
If you were dating a girl and you really
liked her,
she just happened at boobs like that.
You'd have to go.
Do you?
Do you want to get those taken out?
You want to get a reduction on like
normal?
Yeah.
That looks at.
It.
Looks at what is the vagina like?
Did they show it?
They don't show it,
but look at the waist.
Look at how fucked up that is.
That it will go back real quick.
Sorry.
That image of her waist is like,
it's like a 12 inch waist.
I mean,
that's fucking creepy.
Yeah.
But that's what they want.
You're like fully exaggerated features.
So going back to we were talking about
you want to talk about like this,
that goes back to this core set of core
said,
whoa,
look at her waist.
That goes back to this creepy psychology
of what the figure and men's minds
socially we that has been pushed out
that you want this hourglass thing.
And did they show you video?
I want to see video girl looks real.
That one down.
Uh,
the,
where it says new,
the first new to the left.
That photo kind of looks real right
there while the first one did.
Yeah.
Like that looks weird.
That look real far away.
It looks crazy.
Real.
That was a girl's instagram profile.
Yeah.
You wouldn'T think twice.
She has an instagram page.
This.
Oh my god.
But then again,
how many followers jamie,
look at the size of those fake tits.
There's so ridiculous.
Can you imagine following this?
What does your,
what does your wife say?
Well,
I saw that followed one person.
Go to the upper.
Okay,
go to the right hand side.
That one with the giant tits.
That is so ridiculous.
Petite japanese cooling.
They love that shit.
Hot battery battery inside me.
Keep me hot.
I'm so hot.
I take off my clothes.
Why fit?
So a bank is here.
I can just hear like a asian listeners
tuning out.
Like this is just.
I can't take this anymore.
As I go to the one on the upper left
hand corner,
the top first,
first image of the a way go down.
We'll get that one right there.
Look at that one.
What the fuck man?
Like why are they so big?
Because this is what they.
I guess the idea is that the kind of
people that are Going to buy these are
the kind of people that are either
addicted to porn or anime porn.
I always say that.
I would say it's because they don't get
anything ever,
so they have to go.
Click on.
Click on the image.
one more time,
jamie.
Any of them,
any of them,
and then click on the likes.
14 likes these fucking weird.
I would click on one of them guys.
Click on gonzalo there.
Roland rubric calling you out though,
bro.
I'll be so fucking weird dude.
Why you liking photos?
That's a good job.
Good job on these guys now.
Yeah,
this is gross.
There's going to get gross.
Okay.
Just for us.
Yeah,
they don't.
People don't get to see that.
No,
but let me see if there's a video of
these things moving.
This is what I want to see.
I want to see that.
They're just lying there.
I'm thinking that they're inanimate.
So these sex robots,
when you call them robots,
do they move?
No,
no,
no.
it's not.
No,
they're not called robots.
They're called sex dolls.
It's a doll.
I've heard about a doll.
But these are sex robot.
This as kinky doll.
These are sex dolls,
right?
But the ones in toronto,
houston robot.
This is the same company.
So this,
this is.
Yeah.
It's just sex dolls.
So they don't move kinky.
Estelle was a bull or something like
that.
So I don't think they owe their posable.
Yeah.
What he's doing.
Her dirty looks really painful.
He's grabbing her.
Listen to me.
Let me open Your mouth.
Can get this off the fucking screen for
I vomit.
Oh.
What are you doing?
They're checking the seeds of sex robots
contacting you.
I just got to Texas.
I was like,
sex doll talk.
What the fuck is wrong with you guys?
Yeah,
exactly.
Fuck,
I'll talk.
Hey man,
we're not the ones that are using it.
He's drunk folks.
He's been drinking in my face.
I'm going to.
I'm going to drink more in front of
rogan.
I'm going to smoke pot and I'm going to
upset my investors and I'm going to get
everybody mad.
I have 20 days.
You motherfuckers to zero.
We got.
What we really have to do though for
real is when it's up like the party.
You have to throw like a fucking huge
party.
A party.
You throw a party.
Fucking one sober.
October is over.
Where?
Here?
Why here?
Why?
For us?
Oh,
it's a party.
This is what I want for food.
I want dogs kielbasa.
These following things I would like to
enjoy at your party.
I like the thick crust.
Pizza.
Deep day shift.
A chicago style dude,
go get me polish over there.
from.
From,
from my.
From marco is in chicago.
Was really fun because you could tell
like you were in your element so much
for taking deep breaths.
I was wonderful.
Fucking chicago.
I love iT.
here we went to a bar.
We got steaks.
Like the best part.
We walk out of a state of good
steakhouse in this guy.
Go of chicago,
black hawk who I'm a huge fan of.
Comes up to joe and he's like,
joe rogan.
Joe rogan and he couldn't
believe you were there and you're like,
what's up man?
He's like,
I'm a chicago black hawk.
You're like,
all right.
He was like,
cool,
and you're like,
all man,
you turned them in to you.
Who was that guy?
I was like,
that's a fucking chicago blackhawks,
and I was like,
oh yeah,
joe doesn't give a fuck about.
No.
Yeah,
no,
I'm saying you didn't know it was nice.
The guy.
Oh,
you're super nice.
But I was like,
that's so funny to think that like those
guys are dead.
How he treated you was how people treat
him.
Do you know what I mean?
It was wild to watch how people treat
athletes when they're like pro,
you're my favorite.
This guy was like,
he became a kid again.
He was like,
oh my god,
joe rogen to this restaurant that I
fucking love to go to.
It was,
it was cool to be on the outside of
that,
to watch that happen.
Especially because I'm such a chicago
blackhawks and like I'm such a sports
fan,
so it was just so weird to watch an
athlete kinda act like people acted
them.
Do you know what I mean?
It was fucking,
it was just beautiful to watch.
It was the
weirdest thing that has come out of this
podcast is.
And,
and again this is not just for men,
the podcast is for whoever the fuck legs
it,
but men don't get a whole lot of
examples of men that are allowed to just
be themselves be guys.
Yeah.
Just because everybody's worried about
getting fired from something.
Yup.
Everybody's worried about saying the
wrong thing.
Or like when I said that I'd like that
song that girls sang.
I really like it.
Yeah.
It's a good song and I think she's got
really good points.
I'm not saying it so that someone likes
me more.
I'm not.
I mean,
I'm saying like maybe as men,
especially me as a guy with three
daughters,
you should see,
I should consider and we should all
consider what it's like to be a girl,
you know,
and I've talked to girls who have been
drugged.
I've talked to girls who've had guys
creep on them and do creepy shit to them
and girls that have been sexually
assaulted.
I liked that.
I liked that song.
I like it.
Not that I like sexual assault.
I meant I liked that song.
This is going to get cut up.
I like it.
Is it?
It's going to get edited out of the
context for sure.
I,
I liked,
I liked this woman expressing herself in
an artistic way that represents the real
threat that women face and it's also a
catchy song.
She's got a beautiful voice and I'm
still a man.
Yeah,
you're still.
It's okay.
These things are allowed to coexist.
You don't.
You don't somehow or another become some
sort of a cook or a pussy or it doesn't
mean that you're,
you're a loser or that your.
We all know when someone's faking
something,
when they're giving in totally pressure
and pretending like actress,
use the word wonderful.
Describe a woman's performance.
What we were talking about.
We no fake shit.
We no fake shit and it was very good.
Too much goddamn fake shit in this
world.
So one of the more interesting things
that's come out of this podcast is
because I don't have a person telling me
what to do and I can just be myself.
People like guys go,
oh,
this is like hanging out.
This is what it would be if we were just
hanging out,
but people are listening,
right?
But normal things.
You don't get to just hang out because
when people are listening,
then you've got to tone the language.
she say she can't say things.
Don't say careful.
Don't say it to say that word.
You know why?
Because there's so much misconstrued
nonsense people because people are
allowed to take any opinion that you
have because they don't know your full
opinion.
They knew a piece of what you think here
and they just ripped that out and throw
that into fucking space.
It's recreAtional outrage.
That's what they're there.
They're finding a nice little juicy
target like,
oh,
let's go after it and it'll be whatever
the fuck it is when whoever's next,
whether it's chris hardwick or who or
whoever gets called out for something
and someone whether they're guilty or
not,
who gives a shit,
let's pile on to that motherfucker right
and ruin their life for a couple of
weeks and this is what's going on in
this world and it's.
It's not good for anybody.
It's for men.
It's not good for women.
There's only one good piece of it at
all.
If you are a piece of shit like harvey
weinstein,
if you're a fucking turd and your rape
women,
yes,
then you're going to get got and it's
good that you got got,
but even him,
man,
have you seen the new article article
where the woman who is accusing him of
sexual assault,
the da is talking about throwing it out
of court now because they found a
computer log.
The girls who was accusing harvey
weinstein,
one of them have actual sexual assault.
I will send it to you,
jamie,
so that you can pull it up.
It was on the New York post page six.
It was on page six yesterday.
Judge dismisses one.
Is that today?
Okay.
So this is.
They did,
they decided to dismiss it because this
woman had a uh,
uh,
she,
they got ahold of her computer because
of her former employer or a former
employee,
a who said,
look,
this is not how this girl describe this
aisle.
I want tO watch the video.
She failed the boards.
Have video of them having a
conversation,
right?
I don't think so.
This is a different one.
This is a girl who gave harvey weinstein
a blow job.
And she said,
look,
I'm going to send you the actual thing
that I got here.
Jamie,
hold on.
I'm sorry.
Give me one second.
um,
and her former employee was like,
this is not what she said.
This is not what she said to me.
And they were,
there were saying that it was in danger
of being thrown out and now it is thrown
out.
So she lied about what it was.
So the judge was like,
fuck this shit yet.
Well don,
they essentially said that this is just,
she look,
there are actual sexual assault victims
and then there are people,
there's also people I think that are
crazy,
but you don't have a real accurate
memory of things that have happened and
so they can paint themselves as a victim
and be deceptive about it in
voluntarily.
I think that's entirely possible.
Sure.
I think there's a certain amount of
people that are just delusional and they
just don't see things accurately.
Did you get the texts that I sent you?
But I also,
but you all.
But I also still know that harvey
weinstein is,
is a fucking a sexual assault.
There's just too many women that are
saying that he forced himself on them
and he did an audio of him without girl.
You heard that audio?
I heard of it.
I didn't listen to some of the
transcripts,
but there was also that um,
so I'll make this bigger.
So my stupid old eyes can see it.
You say old eyes,
I can get bigger too.
Um,
she accused weinstein of forcing her to
perform oral sex,
but a prior employee of evan's turned
over personal writing.
She'd left in the company's computer,
which appeared to contradict the grand
jury testimony.
The writings indicated was consensual
friendly.
A source told the post that has caused a
split in the manhattan manhattan
district attorney's office.
Some believe the charges should be
dropped if there's a problem with this
complaint.
And then it was just so it was dropped.
Yeah,
there you go.
Listen,
it's the whole.
It's hard.
It's hard man,
because like you,
you don't want to say,
oh,
these girls were all lying because
they're not of course.
But one of them could be lying.
Sure.
Yeah.
And when one of them's lying,
they've got to do what they did and
throw that case out.
But then he's going to say,
look,
it's all fabricated.
Well,
there's people that will be opportunists
in the face of a scandal.
So There's a scandal where someone is
actually legitimately done awful things
and someone is going to stand up and say
he did awful things to me when really
they just fuck the guy because they
wanted to advance their career.
You're right.
I would,
I would always argue the majority of
people that get involved in this thing
probably aren't full of shit.
There is always is always going to be
people that want to capitalize.
There's a,
there's a real problem.
Human nature.
People do that all the time in every
facet.
And that people that lied about
September 11th where they were,
these people environmentally lie about
everything.
But I think there's power.
Oh,
not matt lauer,
the other guy.
Brian williams.
William,
sorry.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He loved.
Well,
it wasn't just hillary clinton lied
about it to come.
Remember?
Yeah.
She lied about a bullets were flying
buyer and people were like,
no,
no.
There's no bullets.
Nope.
We didn't have anywhere near political.
Remember that wasn't that.
There's something about hillary clinton
lied about being in the middle of a
gunfire situation.
Looking people,
they,
they exaggerate.
They make things up and some people are
just full of shit and then there's
people that are delusional and they have
a problem with reality and they might
legitimately believe it's something
awful happened to them.
There.
There are people that do things like
that,
like it's not all deceptive.
There's people that have legitimate
mental issues and they have a paranoid
schizophrenia to whatever extent,
you know,
whether it's mild or horrible,
but they have a delusional perception of
the world around them.
They think people are out to get them
totally,
and then those people get caught up in
the mix.
There's also,
there's also selective memory,
right?
There's also manipulation of selective
memory.
there's,
there's a lot of study about people that
have convinced themselves that something
happened,
but It really didn't happen that that's
a real thing.
They really believe and they're not
lying because in their brain that is
literally with their brain has
kind of categorize and formulated was
that thing did happen.
They've told themselves that enough
where it's been convinced in their own
mind that it did happen
to.
Someone's trying to explain that about
oj.
They were saying that oj has lied so
many times about what happened that
night that he might in his own mind,
he didn't actually believe he didn't do
it.
That's wild as fuck,
but the human memory,
like neil degrasse tyson was trying to
explain this to me that when you,
when you were taught,
when you're talking about memory,
you are literally talking about the
worst form of evidence that we know of.
The memory.
Your memory is.
First of all,
your memory really is your memory of
your memory.
It's not even your memory.
It's a memory of you recounting what you
used to remember and then sort of
reestablishing it in your narrative of
the past.
RighT.
It's,
it's a recounting of a thing you tried
to recount.
Yeah,
like I'm pretty sure when that girl blew
me,
when I was 16,
I did have my ears ringing because I
remember like,
wow,
that's crazy,
and it's never happened since,
but maybe not now.
I'm pretty sure it probably.
Yeah,
it happened.
Here's what I know.
She did rape me.
She didn't punch me in the face and hit
me over the head with a frying pan to my
ears rang.
She didn't do that.
It will be funny.
Zero hit you over the head.
It'd be funny if my head went to the
shape of a frying pan like those
cartoons and then I had to go because
you can see it's back to normal.
That's a hard.
I came.
My head was in a fried.
I don't know man.
It's.
Hi.
I'm optimistic.
This is what I think about when when
people talk about the,
the the divide between men and women.
I don't see it that much in real life
and they'll see it in my actual
interactions on the internet.
I see it.
Yeah.
That's the problem with the internet.
The internet is just writing things and
you're not being there with the person
and talking to the person so you don't
know if the people are writing things
are reasonable.
You don't know if the people were angry.
No.
You don't know.
There's no legitimacy.
There's no legitimization to the
internet anymore because it can come
from memory one anywhere at any time and
the problem I have with,
with,
with these growth movements that get
like crazy is you're like,
are they talking to anybody else besides
their little internal group?
like are you talking to anybody other
than the people that you know because if
you're not,
you're not getting any sort of outside
opinion or sources.
You're just listening to people that
agree with you already.
That the echo chamber thing is so
annoying.
To me it's like as annoying on the same
page.
It's like,
yeah,
stop that.
That doesn't.
That doesn't help any case at all.
Are you?
Are you actually trying to see what the
other side is saying?
I think there are some people that do a
good job.
I don't want to mention names of life,
but there are some people that I follow
online that do a great job of like
trying to have good discourse of right
and left
like bill o'reilly.
Okay.
That was a guy.
I just think like there are some people
that I like online that do have a good
date fucking
balance it out,
but I.
BuT nowadays if you're.
But if you balance like you union,
you get criticized because you don't
stick to one way.
Well,
here's what's interesting.
I tried to be very,
very balanced,
but I lean way more left than I do.
Right?
Way more left,
but you say that I get way more accused
of being someone who favors the right
quarter.
I left people right than I do.
Being someone who favors the left by,
right.
People who are outwardly espouse left
wing ideas like universal basic income,
gay rights,
gay marriage,
women's rights.
Go down the line,
welfare,
food stamps.
I'm supportive of all these things,
but I get accused way more being a right
wing person by people on the left
because do even of being a left wing
person that people on the right.
When I say I'm left wing,
that's because that's because you don't.
You don't come.
The problem I have with the fly.
Yeah,
you don't comply.
I don't comply or don't comply.
I don't comply.
They get my.
That's my.
That's my biggest issue with any for any
far stretching side of the of political
party.
When you don't comply,
they fucking get mad.
They get mad when we were talking about
earlier that it is a form of fascism
that they're trying to get you to figure
out what they want you to behave like,
how they want you to talk.
They want you to comply with that and
stick to the script.
Fit in this box,
joe,
or you're not one of us.
Stick to the groove and we won't bitch
because we don't do that shit.
You don't do that shit,
But b also because I know you fucks turn
on each other internally.
They fucking light each other up.
Is ever progressive enough?
Nope.
They will always try when they run out
of targets that if,
if the whole world was progressive,
they would find people who are less
progressive.
They were fine.
People who are not willing to suck that
muslim,
queer,
gender,
nonbinary,
Iran secretary,
whatever,
whatever that guy's dick is because he's
a.
He has a penis.
You're some sort of a homophobes.
They would find a rezone.
Yeah,
that guy.
Glamour.
They'd find a reason for him forever for
them.
She them zero,
but that's what I mean like.
Yeah,
but I've talked about this shit on
stage.
I'm not going to tell my joke,
but.
No,
but why can't.
Why?
Why the labels?
Yeah.
Why the labels just be your,
your own.
Because people like to be tribal.
That's right.
But.
But all that does is that categorize as
you and then they get mad at category.
You want your,
you are subjecting yourself.
I didn't do that.
You told me you're the debt debt.
Debt,
debt,
debt.
I don't tell you joe.
I'm a white,
straight male who's irish and italian
who loves her feet and a doggy style and
that.
And I'm also kind of catholic,
but you know,
my mom got a divorce so I can't be all
the way.
Don't think that applies to a british
iraqi gay nonbinary and also identifies
as muslim person.
I think you're out of your life.
I identify as an irish italian,
straight white male from chicago who I
just think we don't need all these
labels.
You glamour.
You're allowed to be whoever you fucking
want to be and I support the fuck out of
who you are.
Always do your shit.
Well,
it's almost always people that don't
have a lot of other things going for
them because you have to,
like when someone says stephen hawkings,
identifying as a british identified as a
dead guy now when he was alive.
Yeah.
Brilliant.
British physicist slash heterosexual
atheist,
a heterosexual identified who by the way
was um,
uh,
ribs of,
riddled with infidelity.
I've never met a guy so not capable of,
of cheating and found a way to cheat on
his wife.
Well,
apparently you could still get it up.
Oh,
well apparently even though his body
didn't move,
his could feel things.
That was his side.
The scientist,
he used to go to a.
Eric weinstein told me about this.
I was like,
what?
He's like,
yeah,
he's a freak.
And I was like,
wait,
what?
And he's like,
yeah.
He used to go to strip clubs and there's
like videos of him like rolling into a
strip club in the wheelchair.
Like he would go.
That was his thing.
Where'd you hear littered with
infidelity?
What'd you hear?
That he cheated on his wife all the
time.
We were in that fucking movie.
the whole reason that he.
Well,
I mean the whole reason that he left his
wife was because he fell in love with
somebody else,
but wasn't it like a nurse?
There was taking care of it.
The truth was that he was the nurses.
If you google,
if you google stephen hawking,
he was affiliated.
He was always fucking around.
Come on man.
Yeah.
Once he got a taste of the good light
bulbs.
Yeah.
Once he got with that cosmology cash.
You know what also,
he's my back and a play by the rules.
The world dealt me the shittiest.
God please.
I'm a super genius and you know what?
I fucking agree.
Do whatever the fuck you want to do and
you want to leave me lists.
You should leave me.
Why would you only fuck me?
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm barely here.
I'm a machine now.
I use this finger to talk.
Know if somebody was his eyes and his
fucking in his mouth.
At some point you couldn't even use his
hands.
It was this size,
right?
Wasn't it as kind of a thing where he
could kind of click?
He would do.
He would.
He would look at something too.
He had a thing where it was taken away.
Then he would look at shit and it was
me.
I want to see your ass hole.
Can you sit on my face?
Face face.
Don't kill me though,
man.
Figure out the universe.
Don't smother me with your pussy.
I need to figure out how stars are black
holes real or is it just a brown star?
Please?
I don't want to drown in your pussy.
I'm still on the subject of dark matter.
I'm trying to figure out the universe
before I know in my pants.
That's the.
That's one of the strippers that he
hooked up with was called dark matter.
Jada.
I'm trying to figure out.
Dark matter.
I could see her with a big old fur coat
long for a bush pickle message with a,
with a a pencil because she.
Her nails are too long.
Long text.
That dark matter.
Is that possible that you could grow
your fingernails to girls with long
nails?
They probably have a terrible time
texting.
Well,
how did they touch with.
They try to touch with their finger.
Right?
But if you have a crazy ass long nails,
you'd be like,
oh,
I always text the whole time,
but then you gotta use your nose just to
get to the microphone thing.
That's what this is.
Just read about how this worked for red
sensors on his glasses.
See what I'm saying?
I was on his eyeball movements in his
cheek,
which then translated into a software
program that allows them to navigate a
system without his hands and then
eventually turned into his speak as text
to speech.
I just want to fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Speak functionality,
which takes text,
text and turns into speech in his iconic
voice.
Yeah.
He apparently he liked that voice and
didn't want to upgrade it because like
siri,
like if you talk to who do you,
do you have a specific kind of cereal.
My siri is an australian lady.
Like,
hey siri,
what's cracking bitch?
I don't know how to respond to that,
but that's what I have.
I have a.
Okay.
Does she love me?
Didn't she?
Would you like me to search the web for
love?
that might've.
I think it's the same one.
It's british.
I think we have the same one.
I used to have an australian lady.
They swapped me out the new,
uh,
maybe they don't like Australia.
The new upgrade his voice in 2004.
It was a good enough stick with it.
This is how I talk.
I will always be this.
That man.
It was funny for.
You heard his voice.
He was like,
yo,
what's up with stephen hawking?
Real hardcore.
Yeah.
Like a super ghetto voice dose up to
talk to you.
G up in this pitch out this
motherfucking.
Fuck.
What's up with this door here?
drinking hennessy and coke.
Trying to find out what the fuck is
happening with black matter.
Black matter is his.
That's his alter ego.
Black matter.
There'll be.
That would be a great stripper name.
Google sTripper.
Black matter stripper black exist.
She does.
Or porn star first start with stripper.
Oh,
that's fine.
That might be a better porn star name.
Then stripper named black matter.
That will be out.
Actually,
there used to be.
They used to be a dark matter.
Dark matter.
Dark matter,
black matter.
Black matters.
Now we're going to get better.
I can't wait to the internet.
Lights that up.
Shoot.
Fucking racist piece of shit headed guy.
The skinhead.
Never end.
Redheads skinhead.
Find a.
An exotic dancer named dark matter.
No god.
If there was any branches that listening
right now,
but on the dl down at spearmint rhino,
trying to keep it on a steak tip.
The of them.
Atlanta strip Clubs in dark black ones.
What was it?
What's it called?
A little wayne would go and throw money
in the area.
What's.
What's the.
What's the most popular one in atlanta?
Jamie knows you're there in the black
culture.
You know about black twitter,
black twitter.
Jamie.
Jamie will tell us
real famous one,
right?
Yeah.
There's like fast ones where people get
joanna.
it's like the most famous one.
It was a gunfights there and shit.
The magic city.
Magic city.
That's the most famous one in atlanta.
That's the big one.
That's like the one dark.
Ladies and gentlemen,
coming to the stage.
Dark matter.
You're a magic city.
Come to magic city.
Oh shit.
Shop shop.
let's see.
What do they have to look at?
Photos.
The photos was.
Will the thuggish looking?
The guy had a flat brimmed hat on.
Go to photos.
Look at that.
is this where you want to go?
Oh wait,
whoa.
Damn.
Okay.
We gotta go that dark matter.
Dark matters.
The one,
the third one with the.
But jesus go to the far right.
Far right upper.
That's dark matter.
That's our girl.
Kapow will come.
It doesn't wait.
What the fuck?
Like photos of the night.
Oh,
what was going on on January 12th?
Look at that dude.
What is going on January 12th is that
snoop dogg,
who's the guy with the white hood,
some fake snoop dogg will get them
thuggish.
These are thuggish looking.
Oh,
he's got to look at whenever you got
people that are standing there with
fanning out hundred dollar bills,
like enjoys drinking Fiji water.
Yeah.
That's not my place.
I like all these girls to the main
stage.
Dark matter,
living gentlemen,
dark matter,
get.
Who do you think was the first guy that
came up with the strip club?
dj voice?
I don't know,
but that motherfucker has permeated the
entire culture.
you can't hear that,
you know,
to the main come to the main stage.
Rain ladies and gentlemen.
It's river.
a nice round of applause for lexus.
how about a nice round of applause for
kia sorento.
It's weird how things like that
happened.
Like top 40 dj voiCe.
Very similar.
It's a similar voice but that.
But that's a weird thing.
How did broadcast journalism broadcast
journalism in college and they teach you
that they teach you broadcast voice
while.
I mean they kind of teach you about
intonation,
so I think people get so stuck in that
that they learn it and it like this,
like like web kit wbbm wk qx 95 nine.
It's the moose on the radio this morning
with joe rogan traffic at nine from lisa
guys today and it's,
it's the same rhythm.
They all have the exact same rhythm and
I think it's just because it was learned
and then they hear other people do it
and it's just such a monkey hear monkey
do,
but there's a comfort level in imitating
it.
Well,
because it's rhythmic.
It's really isn't true.
I mean truly.
When they teach you in school,
they teach you about the rhythm of the
voice.
What did they teach you?
Well,
they teach you that there's.
There's rhythmic waves too.
It's the exact same thing that happened
to on air journalist,
like local news.
It's the same way when someone goes and
on 95th street,
that's where it all went down.
They teach you about rhythmic ways to
lead into the next piece.
They say it's be.
It teaches.
It teaches the listener or the watcher
to get to be prepared for the next
thing.
It's almost like a.
We,
I swear on god,
that dark matter search little farther
and I've been real serious journalism.
No,
my shit's bullshit.
Give you what you really got.
Apparently a porn star named dark dark
man.
Oh yeah.
Where is she?
They just teach you about rhythms
because.
Because it's,
it's,
it's easy for the listener to hear in
the morning to hear people go,
oh no,
no,
no.
There's dark matter.
So there's also a featuring dark matter.
And is that a girl or a guy?
I'm not sure.
We'll get pornhub is just falling apart
on us.
Like a bunch of parody.
I'm dark matter what is,
there's a thing that people do,
like jamie was on the phone once,
getting some tech information from this
lady sounds right.
Put her on speaker phone while he's
typing and she had the most annoyed,
you know that thing that people do.
It's called uptalk.
Oh yeah.
Uptalk is so annoying.
Tech talk.
Here's a way that they taught that lets
you know that they're in,
whether it's like a very left wing
technologically savvy way of talking
upslope tech top date,
but it's all tech people.
Yeah.
But it,
it becomes an accent.
Like if it was from Georgia or something
like that would be a recognizable
accent.
Like,
oh,
that's how they talk.
And Maryland.
Right.
Have you ever talked to someone from
baltimore?
Baltimore,
baltimore,
ryan sickler?
Yeah,
cyclones.
Margaret says baltimore.
Tuesday,
tuesday,
tuesday.
Yeah.
My friend john rollo.
Shout out to john raul.
He's from baltimore.
They have that same kind of.
It's a very boston,
very recognizable at boston's.
Got that fucking article,
uptalk recognizable way of talking that
lets you know that I'm going to agree
with everything that is in like the
zeitgeists of left wing progressive and
the cloud.
The cloud.
It'S in the cloud.
Does that the best?
Fred armisen I think does that.
The best armisen knows how to like fred
armisen.
What is that?
From portlandia.
Oh,
okay.
What is she doing?
She's talking about.
I've talked.
Let me here
question.
It doesn't bother me that much unless
they do it a lot and it gets really
annoying.
Talking with connie chung.
Focus
on the positive things in yourself.
That supermodel cindy crawford.
She's going to do it again.
Oh,
I didn't have the opportunities then.
The popular term for it is talking to
everyone,
but you don't have to be a fashion model
or a teenager to uptalk came ikea
because you can hear it on commercials.
I mean,
it's kind of self serve or even coming
out of the mouth of a doctor on the
president's healthcare task force
because I see the problem from a
different point of view.
She came to the table and said,
my name is belinda.
Dr cynthia macklemore is a linguist in
philadelphia who's work takes 10
[inaudible] 94.
That's how fucking old this is.
This huge thing for her doctorate.
Intonation was way more exaggerated.
Now.
It's interesting what they were talking
about in [inaudible] 94.
Some of the artists would make
announcements and take pledges.
I need your form.
It's not a request for direct response,
but for attention,
which is the kind of response people may
think that uptalk conveys the
uncertainty,
but dr mcnamara says it can be used in a
number of specific way or do you can.
You can use the rise to convey
uncertainty.
You can use a rise to hold the floor.
You can use a rise to convey,
do you understand what I'm saying or do
you hear me or do you agree with me or
do you approve of me?
All of those things.
That's very interesting here.
No language.
Describe what it is because it has been
adopted.
See if you can google tech talk up
talks.
What I was looking for.
Let's see if you can find like a because
it's way more exaggerated now and the
people that you know who I'm talking
about,
the woman that was talking to you on the
phone,
how crazy was she?
it was weird the way she was talking.
Just take a presentation too.
So what kind of.
Are you working on berenger x and is
two.
One six.
Is that it?
I felt like we were in a sketch when she
was talking to him.
I'm like this is an snl,
but she had no answers for him and so it
was like she was like bullshitting him.
Well that's your place.
That's to placate to pass time.
That's like anybody,
anybody in that tech world that anyone
that's helping you with like a.
Any sort of troubleshooting.
I find that too when I do that with
apple,
when I text them about issues,
everything is like this weird play
kidding.
Like,
oh I know.
I can't believe you're having that
prOblem.
Well,
let's just figure it out.
It's almost like this like patting you
on the head,
like subservient.
Like are you okay in your pod?
Do you need more food in your pod?
Oh,
so you have an issue with the sonos
player.
It's all apple.
All lap,
all apple.
Apple has a sneaky,
you know,
the sonos thing works flawlessly with
the apple music service.
Loyalty for flawless spotify.
but when you try to get the shit right
off your phone,
that's when it problem.
So they've done some sneaky shit.
Force you into that.
Yeah.
That forces you into using their
subscription service.
Sure.
So they've hijacked sonos.
They've,
they've done some shit where they
inserted a little fuck.
Do you into the co's,
apple,
dick,
a little bit of apple.
Did they make it work better with their
home pod speaker?
Of course.
Probably 100 percent.
We're.
Come on.
It's a much better alternative.
What we suggest switch over to home pod
and that way we can listen to everything
you say all the time.
We're listening in.
When you mute us,
he just released a new one.
They released a pixel three within new
speaker dock,
motherfucker of a thing that the new
update on spotify has a built in thing.
So you could so you can like ask for a
song to be played because it's not
probably built into apiary or thing.
Yeah.
But you have to like allow the
microphone and beyond.
Of course,
it's not a big issue.
It's not going to listen to you jerk
off.
Did you let,
do you allow the microphone to me?
Um,
why is there a piece of tape over the
camera?
We'd like to see your car.
I'd like to see you on the webcam on.
Want to see your car.
Let me see.
The only the back of your dick.
It's not even the front is the front
facing you.
What's the big deal?
I took the phone under my cost.
If I see your balls?
Yeah,
that's what I do.
I put the camera right under my sack.
I rest my nut,
sack the camera.
That.
So if you see,
I think you see a red screen of my boss,
like put your balls like him.
You draped your balls like over like a
light bulb when they looked through my
lens.
Motherfuckers look ahead.
Look ahead.
Okay,
go ahead.
That knife is very.
It's very fun to play with.
Big beefy knife stab or something.
Let's wrap this bitch up tino.
Let motherfuckers know what you're
doing.
You got damn hilarious comedy come.
She was on the road bro.
We had some.
We had so much.
We got to go in the next year.
We're going to write a whole new act 25
minutes,
right?
Hurry up 25.
I'm trying.
I wrote all night last night.
I got home after the store.
I did a lot of writing.
Yeah.
I've got almost nothing out of it.
I'm not going to talk them.
I won't talk about anything.
But you had but you weren't.
There was a few new things that you had
that I saw.
I got some new shit.
Yeah.
Last night.
It was really good swinging,
swinging for the fence,
looking for gems though.
Come see me.
Come see me looking for some,
uh,
some uh,
fake gems.
I got.
I'm in calgary,
I'm in calgary next week.
And then in New York at caroline's on
broadway the following week,
Please check me out and understand
tino.com.
Cheeto santina on all of them.
Platform.
Alright fuckers.
See ya.
Well.